so walter isaacson what is the link
between Averell Harriman Ben Franklin
Steve Jobs Henry Kissinger
and ADA Countess of Lovelace yeah I
think they're all creative minds and
that's what's interested me throughout
my career a lot of people write about
sports heroes or literary figures but to
me it's people can combine different
disciplines like the arts and the
sciences away then Franklin did the way
Ada Lovelace did the way Albert Einstein
did and make creative leaps of the
imagination you know we talk about
innovation so often it's almost drained
of its meaning and I've always liked to
write about real people who are in a
situation whether it be Averell Harriman
after World War two and you have to
create a whole new world order of things
like NATO in the world back in the
Marshall Plan or Steve Jobs who says
okay we're now in a digital revolution
we have to make it personal these are
people who use Steve Jobs is word were
able to think different they were able
to think out of the box and so I want to
try to explore the creative mind and how
it works what are the themes in all of
your books though seems to be the
connection to spirituality in some sense
I think everybody I've written about
believed that whatever they did it was
part of something larger than themselves
I remember sitting with Steve Jobs near
the end of his life and I asked him you
know what why did you do what you do
what was the meaning of it and he said
life is like a river you get to take
things out of the river really cool
things that people have done out of them
you know but they put before you and the
river great devices or you know great
ideas but after a while you realize it's
not how much you get to take out of the
river
it's what you put back into the river
what you leave behind so that your
spirit is still manifest after you've
been gone and whether it's Albert
Einstein or Benjamin Franklin or anybody
else they get have a connection to
something supernatural something
somewhat larger than themselves from
2011 your book on Steve Jobs opening
sentence in the early summer of 2004 I
got a phone call from Steve Jobs
well you know I didn't call you you know
I had written a biography of Benjamin
Franklin one of Albert Einstein and said
why don't you do me next and I must
admit my first reaction was okay Ben
Franklin Albert Einstein you you know
but then I realized he's been sick he'd
been fighting cancer and that we don't
always look at creative minds in
business and entrepreneurship and to me
to be able to get very close to and try
to peel back the layers on you know from
the greatest business and technology
innovator of our day and generation was
going to be something truly special I've
known him since around 1984 when he came
to Time magazine to show off the
original Macintosh and you know we had
remained moderately good friends off and
on ever since especially when I was
editing time and he had something he
wanted on the cover of Time we'd have a
great meal together and he would tell me
you know how awesome the product was and
so I really liked Steve Jobs and I liked
his passion and so when he gave me a
call I realized this is something
special I'll get to get up close to a
real genius
I asked Jobs why he wanted me to be the
one to write his biography I think
you're good at getting people to talk he
said well he was up you know he was
somebody who understood the power of
listening and I think I learned that
from him a little bit too because when I
started working with him I'd asked a
whole lot of questions and sometimes
they'd have all sorts of premises and
then finally I realized that if I just
let him go if I just sort of say iPod
and then he would go on for an hour or
two I could really listen and try to
pick up the rhythms of the way his mind
worked so you know I'm not necessarily
the best academic historian and you know
I may not even be the best you know
reporter when it comes to writing books
but I'm pretty good and just getting
people to be willing to talk to me and I
hope that's because I the listen and I'm
lucky having been at Time magazine or
CNN if I call up and ask to speak to a
Larry Page I'm more likely than the you
know average person to be able to get
through so I feel I should try to do
that reporting I should go visit good
more you know Moore's Law in his house
and I should you know spend time with
Wozniak or spend time you know with a
Larry Page because I've been blessed to
have that luckiness
of having access to some of these people
just because I've been a journalist my
whole life and so that's what I try to
bring to the party there'll be people
who will take the Steve Jobs book or the
innovators book and they'll be able to
do better analysis of what does this
really mean how does this lead to
leadership lessons but for me what I do
is I can call people up sit down listen
try to get the quotes right and put it
there as if it's a first draft other
people who might be able to analyze
things from the book so is this book
Steve Jobs and authorized biography not
in the technical sense of that term
because when Steve and I taught he kept
saying I don't want to read the book
first because Steve said to me that one
of the things that made Steve Jobs what
he was is that he was brutally honest
he said I've always tried to be brutally
honest and I want you to be brutally
honest in the book and it's going to be
hard until he said I'm not going to ask
to read the book before it comes out I'm
not going to have any say over but he a
user an anecdote or not he said all we
did six months after it comes out in
fact that's why at the summer of 2011
after he stepped down from Apple we just
as CEO of Apple we discuss when should
the book come out he said well let's
make you know I think you should make
the last scene the seat you know when I
step down as CEO of Apple and so I did
and the book went to the printers and I
was hoping hoping he was going to be
alive when the book came out in fact he
told me and last time we talked which is
after I turned the book in he said well
I'm not going to I promise you I wasn't
going to read it right when it came out
but I'll read it six months later and
this was in late August and that made me
feel good I thought
a he's going to beat the cancer one more
time he's going to live another half
year a year maybe two years but then of
course we were not so lucky
so he has no idea well I did sit with
him and read parts of the book to him
especially the last chapter the last
chapter is where I take a lot of things
he told me and I bring it together and
let him have the last word for four or
five pages in the book where you know
from different interviews I took his
thoughts his broad thoughts about why he
did what he did what made him creative
what was the meaning of life with him
and so I had put those together and
really put him together from two or
three separate formal interviews I had
had and I wanted to read it out loud to
him just to make sure he was comfortable
with it I also there's some things in
the book where he's you know personal
were tough on people or you know
anecdotes I'm not really where I would
want in books and I made sure he knew
about each one of those especially ones
but I thought he might want to like
where he doesn't give somebody stock up
there's always mean to somebody whatever
I wanted to let him explain his side of
it so anything in the book that I felt
might be a little tough that he wouldn't
like I made sure he knew about it
beforehand because that was the way
Steve Jobs was you know he didn't try to
sugarcoat things if he thought you
weren't going to like something he'd say
it outright that's a little hard for me
to do I'm not quite as brave or
courageous as Steve was but I learned
from him and so the last few interviews
with him I'd go over things in the book
that I thought he would not like and if
you go to the index and under Steve Jobs
you will find mood swings of offensive
behavior of and there's five line of
pages where offensive behavior of is in
there and a couple other things as
prankster in primal scream therapy well
you know that was something that I was
as I say felt very fortunate is that he
let me get very up close to talk about
things like his primal scream therapy or
talk about you know example
when he was really tough on people and
he encouraged me to be honest about it
and we would talk about those things so
you know I in some things I felt by the
end of this process I knew more about
him than I even knew about myself
because he's a very sot was a very
self-reflective individual he understood
himself extraordinarily well and once he
started peeling away the layers he was
very willing to talk about it and
fortunately for me repeatedly he
encouraged me just put it all in every
now and then I'd say and there were a
few things out left out though a few
things I just thought well unnecessarily
painful to some other people and didn't
really give you much of an insight on
Steve and so I'd go over them with my
wife and that's a you know that that
story should be left out that will
actually hurt this person and it won't
help the reader that much but every time
I'd ask him he'd say put it in whether
it's about his previous girlfriend
whether it was about you know the
daughter he had before he got married
all of these things I say usually what
he said I told you put those things in
was he smart you right no not
exceptionally instead he was a genius we
know I compare them and contrast them to
an absolutely wonderful smart guy of
course Bill Gates and Bill Gates had you
know can more of what you would call
conventional mental processing power I I
marvel and watch Bill Gates take large
amounts of information sometimes two
screens on his desk screens would have
four windows on him and he'd be
processing the information and just be
absolutely brilliant Steve was not
brilliant in that way he didn't have
that analytical processing power what he
had was an intuitive genius he could
just have a feel for things I feel for
what people would like a feel for beauty
a feel for what would work and so to me
that's what I meant by genius I've been
taught in Albert Einstein who I wrote
about which is Albert Einstein was not
the best physicist in Europe in 1905 in
fact he was a third class patent
examiner
in the Swiss Patent Office because he
could even get his PhD they kept
rejecting his thesis he couldn't get a
job at a university so you wouldn't say
oh he is by conventional standards you
know the greatest physicists mind of
1905 but he was the greatest genius he
was able to make imaginative and
intuitive leaks now I would never put
know who Steve Jobs ever put Steve in
the same quantum orbit as Albert
Einstein but there was a similarity
which is that the genius of Steve Jobs
came from making intuitive leaps
imaginative leap questioning received
wisdom and that's what Ben Franklin did
that's what Steve Jobs did that's what
Albert Einstein did is question things
at you and I might say are obvious
question the received wisdom of a Newton
writing at the beginning of the
Principia that time marches along
second-by-second irrespective of how we
observe it and you get this patent clerk
Albert Einstein saying how do we know
that how would we test that how would we
take two clocks and try to synchronize
them so we could test that likewise with
Steve Jobs people didn't know we needed
a thousand songs in our pocket you know
we you and I we had Walkman we had you
know mp3 players they want a big part of
our lives but Steve was able to have a
feel for beauty and a feel for customer
experience that to me made him the
greatest intuitive genius of the digital
age and that's what I meant by that
sentence Walter Isaacson there is one
aspect that Steve Jobs had a role in
with this book and that that was the
cover we've got a couple of different
covers and the original we're going to
show on the air and then we're going to
show you the paperback cover as well
what was his concern about the cover
well when I first did a cover I was with
Simon & Schuster and it was sort of an
apple is the event it was just a test
cover they were doing and once he got
mad he got very mad now landed once I
was on the way to see him was it landed
at the San Francisco Airport I've got
my iPhone it was the thing you least
want to see which is seven missed phone
calls from Steve Jobs Oh something's
actually was Lloyd I thought maybe
something happened with herself so I hit
return phone call answers instantly and
he starts just reaming me out yelling at
me saying you have no taste I thought
you know I'd ideally is talking about
and I kept saying I kept trying to in
the jack like what tell me what you're
upset about what would he said that
cover and I don't even know what he's
talking about but apparently the cover
that time issue so they put it in some
online catalog
said that covers the ugliest thing I've
ever seen I don't want to cooperate with
you anymore because you're going to put
an ugly cover on the book and I said
well I'm sorry I hadn't really thought
about the cover yet the book you know
not even finished and he said unless you
agree to let me have some input in the
cover
I'm not going to cooperate it anymore
well that was the easiest decision I
ever had to make
so within a half a second I say great
help me you know help suggest a better
cover he said black and white make it
simple we went through a lot of
photographs I love the Albert Watson
photograph that ended up on the cover of
my stack you've just a hardback edition
the oldest Steve Jobs and one with his
you know you probably have it on the
screen now and that's Albert Watson one
of the great photographers at Time
magazine I worked with Albert Watson I
think he did that for Fortune magazine
one of our sister publication but there
were four or five pictures that he was
considering including a one that time
had done later mark Oh Grob picture of
others I was hoping that we could agree
on the Albert Watson picture and we did
by the very end and then he just wanted
that Helvetica type did he say if you
look at it it says you know Steve Jobs
by Walter Isaacson
it's a salsa wreath type meaning it's
got no curly Q's or doodads on it and he
said I like Helvetica it's a very simple
font Steve loved fonts ever since he was
at Reed College that's why in the
Macintosh it's a bitmap display with
dozens of fonts you can use that's why
we now have beautiful computers because
- Steve those details made a difference
I like Helvetica - it's a bold font
actually Benjamin Franklin likes it when
he brought what we call Franklin bold
and stuff - you know those type of funds
they were a lot of them were based on
Helvetica so we used a Helvetica font
the only thing that I pushed back on is
he wanted my name in doctype and his
name in light gray thinking that you
know it was my book and my names and I
said no no this isn't has nothing to do
with me
this book is all about you you
cooperated every word in there is
something built on something you've said
and so I want the Steve Jobs to be in
the darker type and me to be more
recessive and I think that's the way it
turned out but there was maybe eight or
nine conversations and with his own you
know artistic directors and great people
at Apple design directors making sure
that that cover that looks so so simple
it's a pretty simple looking cover to
the lot of work sometimes simplicity is
the ultimate sophistication and
sometimes simplicity is pretty difficult
because the Steve Jobs said and it's
Johnny I've has great design directors
often set simplicity isn't about just
making things easy or taking things out
you have to understand the depth of
something you have to truly go deep and
go hard it's hard work to create
simplicity so you know leave out
something and that's what Steve Jobs was
able to do on the iPod on the iPhone the
iPad the original Macintosh and he
pushed to make sure it was done on the
cover that was his genius why the
younger Steve Jobs on the paperback uh
by the time you know the hardback had
been out for a year just Albert Watson
photograph was iconic Apple Computer had
used it on their posters it was used you
know in the memorial services it had
just become the standard iconic
photograph I think there were people
both at Apple and Simon to choose to
whatever said you know don't keep
building on that one try something I
also saw
the picture and I think it was done for
Rolling Stone in the early 1980s in
which Steve is in the exact same pose
you have it there on the paperback and I
thought well this will just be something
fresh and new Steve's always used the
phrase
think different and I think whether it
was Albert Watson or Apple or Simon &
Schuster everybody felt we had it
wouldn't be thinking different if we use
that and I think Apple felt lightly to
that that iconic and classic image was
something that they owned and I wanted
to make sure that with the paperback
because I think they asked to that we
tried to think different
what was the importance of Laurene
Powell in Steve Jobs like oh she's an
awesome person a person of deep moral
character she's somebody created college
track which helps kids from underserved
neighborhood get into college she was
somebody who deeply deeply understood
Steve Jobs and I think that you know he
would say to me that that you know his
life wouldn't have been the same having
not met her and had you know she not
helped make him who he was so and by the
way the whole family unlike a lot of
powerful people
he wasn't out on the circuit every day
he wasn't having dinner every night with
you know famous people he was having
dinner at the long table in the kitchen
of his house yeah with his three kids
that he and Lorene had wonderful kids
and he would talk deep serious
conversation no playing on the iPhone or
the iPad during dinner and so as a
family man you know Steve was you know
sometimes you rough around the edges
whether it was a home or the office of
work or whatever but the one thing
you'll discover is that even though he's
rough around the edges at work he
developed a team of people who were
deeply loyal to him and more than just
loyal they loved him and likewise at
home you know when he's out he
has around him a family who deeply is
not only loyal to him but deeply loves
him and so when people say these Steve
Jobs was a pretty rough character at
times he had a abrasive personality at
time too could be mean to people
sometimes I'd say yes but I hope you
look at you know what happens is that he
is able to have deep love and deploying
at home and at the office therefore put
it into a context because there's some
people who are mean and nasty and if I
hate him
so Steve had something else it wasn't
just like he was sometimes hard to deal
with he really connected to people he
inspired them he made them love him and
that to me is the essence of Steve Jobs
every now and then I'll read articles
about bosses who try to be like Steve
Jobs and try to be tough or people who
try to be like Steve Jobs and be
brutally honest I take yeah yeah but
don't try this because Steve could pull
it off because deep inside he knew how
to connect with people he knew how to
make them feel inspired he really cared
deeply about other people otherwise he
wouldn't have known you know how to make
such products I connected emotionally to
us and so when you talk about his home
life just as we talked about his office
life there were people around him his
wife his kids who you know truly felt a
deep deep passionate appreciation and
love for him and so it was more complex
and some people make it out and I wish I
conveyed that better in the book in some
way some people read the book it's like
wow he was kind of you know mean I said
wait wait wait I tried over and over
again to say in the book yes he was
tough on people but whether was the
original Macintosh team or his family
people would say I'd give up anything in
the world just to make sure I would have
the opportunity to work with him to be
with him to you know be around him in
the introduction to your book the
innovators your most recent book as an
electronics geeky right who loved heath
and ham radios and then you give your
ham radio address here
high-five done Thomas Peter there we go
tango Papa I'm old enough to have gotten
my first geek experiences soldering
circuits for a ham radio and getting to
play with a ham radio I can remember
when vacuum tubes gave way to
transistors you go on to write that
historians of science or sometimes wary
about calling periods of great change
revolutions because they prefer to view
progress as evolutionary are we in a
revolution or an evolution when a
revolution I think somewhat like the
Industrial Revolution where in the
Industrial Revolution you have the steam
engine that connects with mechanical
processes like looms and weaving
machines or whatever and suddenly we
move into an industrial age where
machines and people are having to work
together to do products I think we have
that here with the microchip the
computer the internet all working
together so the three inventions each of
which would have been important but the
combination of packets which digital
networks with micro processors and micro
chips with sort of the computer
revolution we have leads to a whole new
way of doing not only information but
conducting business conducting your
social life and so it's definitely a
revolution and I do remember I mean I
think there's a person who you know I
quote somebody a Steve Chapin a great
historian of science at Harvard who sat
wrote a book about the Scientific
Revolution I think he begins by saying
there's no such thing as a scientific
revolution and this is a book about it
and then he says it's because of the
thoughts of the people at a time but
they knew they were going through a
revolution so that's why I talk about
just to introduce the book as a kid you
know you you look at a vacuum tube and
you figure out how it works on a circuit
you get to test it to see if it's burned
out or not and you do it you say okay
it's just really an amplifier and an
on/off switch so how does a circuit
do logic just by a step-by-step of
on-off switches like that and so you get
a feel and this is what I worried today
that you know people my daughter's
generation whatever they don't quite
have a feel about how the on/off
switches and logical circuit and logic
gates and boolean algebra all come
together to say oh we can have a machine
that can do these tasks and in fact you
say that math is spiritual you quote
somebody in the innovator saying math is
spiritual well you know that comes from
Ada Lovelace to Ada Lovelace as the
beginning of the innovators as you
mentioned earlier and ADA is a Lord
Byron's daughter the great Romantic poet
and so she has a poetical street and her
but her mother was a mathematician and
as you might imagine knowing something
about Lord Byron his wife lady by him
was not particularly fond of Lord Byron
by the time ADA was growing up he was
little too much of a romantic and poet
and had ADA mainly tutored in
mathematics as if that was some antidote
to you know being romantic or being a
poet and what ADA does is create what
she calls poetical science the
combination of poetry you know with
science of art with technology this is
the essence of everybody I've written
about Ben Franklin does it Albert
Einstein doesn't it's been sort of what
has driven progress since Leonardo da
Vinci of the great engineer and artist
you know combines the two disciplines in
all of his work so you know to me that
notion that there's a connection between
math and natural beauty it's something
important for us to have a feel for just
like a door did now a lot of people who
are not saying I don't love math you
know they get upset that we don't do
enough arts education or humanities
education and schools and I agree we
need the arts and humanities that makes
us who we are
but I also feel that people love the
arts and the humanities should try to
have a
feel to the beauty of math as well just
as you know you'd love Shakespeare you
should they would people would be
appalled some of my humanist friends if
somebody said they didn't know the
difference between Hamlet and Macbeth
but then they would brag that they don't
know the difference between you know a
transistor and a resistor or a gene in
the chromosome or an integral equation
and a differential equation and would
aidanu was that mathematics was just the
good Lords brushstroke for something
beautiful in the universe and that math
was like a line of her father's poetry
people say well math is hard I say take
a line of Lord Byron's poetry you know
what she walks in beauty like the night
that's a pretty tough line but if you're
Ada Lovelace Roy Barnes daughter you can
visualize she walks in beauty like the
night just like ADA could visualize the
beauty of an equation or an algorithm he
writes algorithms to show what a
computer can do in the 1830s so she
realizes that there's beauty in a
mathematical phrase and she can
visualize that just as she can visualize
she walks in beauty like the night and
so that's what I meant by saying that
there's a beauty in both the arts the
humanities on one side and technology
and science on the other side and Walter
Isaacson you have a time line engine
both the innovators such which kicks off
with Ada Lovelace you've got inventor of
email in here you've got sent of
resistors do you want me a cat cetera et
cetera what is it that she contributed
what made the main thing she does when
she sees the beauty of the connection of
art to science is that she comes up with
the concept of a general purpose
computer for example she travels through
the Midlands of England as a young woman
and sees the mechanical looms I talk
about those looms and to use steam
engines and looms and they do think and
they just punch cards so that the looms
would so beautiful pattern so you know
weave beautiful patterns and a father
was a Luddite
literally meaning his only speech in the
House of Lords was defending the
followers
Ned Ludd was smashing these looms
because they thought they put people out
of work but ADA looked at those looms in
tech ah with those punch cards it makes
beautiful patterns she had a friend
named Charles Babbage who was creating a
great numerical calculator trying to
design a numbers crunching machine and
she realized that with punch cards the
analytical engine which was twelve
Babbage's machine as adel wrote and
published and it was unusual for a woman
in the 1830s to publish a scientific
journal she wrote with the punch cards
these machines can do anything not just
numbers do anything that can be noted in
symbols words music art design in other
words a general-purpose computer you
quote her saying the bounds of
arithmetic were out step the moment the
idea of applying cards had occurred the
analytical engine does not occupy common
ground with mere calculating machines it
holds a position holy its own in
enabling a mechanism to combine together
general symbols and successions of
unlimited variety and extent and a
uniting link is established between the
operations of matter and the abstract
mental process that's just a beautiful
way of saying someday we'll have
computers how many people did you get to
talk to how many in centers innovators
did you get to talk to I don't know I
have them in the Bell is mama knows I
assume it was like I don't know
something about hundred of you want to
count all the people because I was
gathering string in 1990 two or three I
became the head of digital media for
Time magazine and time I wanna and so
you'd run into people like Jim Clark and
Mark Andreasen and Mandy Grove who
became Man of the Year at time and you
know people like that and so throughout
the 90s I was always wanting to do a
history of this digital revolution
because each day in generation has a
great revolution or something whether
it's the American Revolution we know
about George Washington Ben Franklin or
the French Revolution or the Industrial
Revolution of the Scientific Revolution
and here I really had this feeling we
were living through this revolution
and I had the chance to meet all these
people so even beginning in the 1990s I
started interviewing people you know I
did a cover story on Bill Gates talking
about what the revolution would bring
Steve Jobs and then when I was focused
on this book for the past six or seven
years off and on was finishing the Steve
Jobs book you know I'd go see good more
or you know mark Andreasen or you know
talk to him at least or
Tim berners-lee who created the world
wide web then sort of an absolutely
truly wonderful guy who actually would
Bob Kahn another wonderful person right
to the Internet protocols in other words
how do you take all these packet switch
networks and make an internet out of it
and so I got a chance to be up close
with these people and to me as I said
earlier in the show what I hope to bring
to the party is doing a little bit of
reporting being able to find these
people and have them talk to me because
there are a lot of people who will be
able to do better analysis and I do but
you know I'm going to get Vint Cerf to
sit around and talk over dinner and tell
me how exactly why the original tcp/ip
protocols were written the way they were
so I think I did a lot of interviews for
the book so Walter Isaacson talking to
the people you did for the innovators
what if you were covering the auto
industry would it be like talking to
Henry Ford and walter Chrysler and the
Dodge Brothers etcetera well sure I mean
these are the people inventing things
obviously the early people early on in
the internet or no longer on the
computers are no longer with us even
Robert Noyce if there's one person I
wish I could have talked to Hue Burton
Robert Noyce is a co-inventor of the
microchip in other words working with
Bill Shockley originally who had created
as part of a team the transistor and all
that does is it takes some
semiconducting material like silicon you
know like sand but silicon that sort of
can conduct electricity sort of but
resists it sort of if you dope silicon
by like making a little bit more impure
adding some boron or something you can
make its semiconducting qualities change
in other words you can make it
off-switch you can make an amplified you
can replace those horrible vacuum tubes
with a transistor and then what Bob
Noyce does is with a group of people
because there's all teamlook figure out
how do you add a lot of transistors
under one chip of silicon that's all a
microchip is is when you have really
cool ways that you can put a little
whole lot of transistors on one chip a
silicon so that's what Bob Noyce does
but he does something even more he
creates a company that's now called
Intel with people but it's a new type of
company that has no great hierarchy it's
not driven from you know an organization
chart with the top down they all sit in
a big old open space and Bob Noyce draws
an org chart for somebody says here's
you at the center and the odd truck is
you connecting to everybody else here so
that whole new way of doing business in
the digital age and he was a mentor to
Steve Jobs but he was very very nice he
was so nice he could never say no to
people which is why he had to form a
partnership with Andy Grove who helped
run Intel at the beginning because Andy
Grove at least knew how to get the
microchips out the door by telling
people no you got to focus or no you
can't do that or you know keep it riding
herd on the rest of the team and so from
Bob Noyce you get the genius of creating
the microchip get the brilliance of
creating a new type of corporate
structure and you also get the concept
of how do you form a right team Bob
Noyce good more Andy Grove is like
putting together a baseball team who's
going to be the pitcher is going to be
the catcher who's going to be the
utility infielder and so to me all those
things came from Bob Noyce I got to
interview Gordon Moore his partner we
all know Moore's law that says that the
exponential rise of the processing power
of a microprocessor but until I talked
to going more a lot about what was it
like to work with Bob Noyce I certainly
got to know Andy Grove who's still with
us and as I said was Man of the Year at
time so you know I got to surround and
figure out about these people I wish I'd
been able to interview eight a Lovelace
and certainly even in Alan Turing I
would have loved interview he's one of
the heroes of the book and I wanted to
make Alan Turing a bit famous because
you know among people who know computers
he's very famous but people don't
probably aren't sure who Alan Turing is
but just as my book was coming out
Benedict Cumberbatch played Alan Turing
in the imitation game and I realize okay
let me see the ground to Benedict
Cumberbatch he's the guy who's going to
make out enjoying famous how true to
life is that moving that movie is very
true to life but like any good movie a
great movie it takes some literary
license or things in the movie that
didn't exactly happen most notably John
can cross I know if you've seen the
movie who's a Russian Soviet spy is not
actually working in hut 8 with Alan
Turing so that's a little bit of a
literary license but was true about the
movie and that's so important there's
some key facts one of which is that he
was an outsider a loner he was gay he
was a long-distance runner he was not
very good at dealing with other people
but he discovers working at Bletchley
Park trying to break the German code
developing the concept of a computer
based on his reading of Ada Lovelace the
universal computing machine he has a
logical computing machine all based on
the general-purpose computer notions of
ADA that if he's going to break the
German code he's going to need to work
together with others and work as a team
so partway through his time at Bletchley
Park Joan Clarke one of the women
programmers in the movie brilliant job
in the movie says to him as do the
others hey we're with you you got to
work collaboratively and he does key
lesson of the movie many other lessons
of the movie Ellen the imitation game
the name of the movie is based on a a
paper that Alan Turing wrote well after
the war about artificial intelligence
can machines think was it and he
believed perhaps you know just knowing
his own personal life that humans and
machines were both pre-programmed and
maybe you'd never be able to tell him
apart the imitation game was
you know at a certain point a computer
could imitate a human you wouldn't know
the difference and therefore yeah
machines are thinking well actually is
not been that successful at reaching
turning like artificial intelligence but
we have been successful at putting
machines in humans working in symbiosis
and partnership like Ada Lovelace talked
about when he writes the paper about the
imitation game
he calls it Ada Lovelace --is objection
lady Lovelace's objection this notion
that machines will never be creative or
think on their own and so that's an
interesting tension and even very
tragically as you know he's pre-program
a wee program they tried to when he's
arrested because of his homosexual acts
they try to give him chemical you know
hormone treatments to stop him as if
he's a machine as if you can reprogram
them chemically he takes a nun stride
for awhile but then he takes an apple
dips it into cyanide and bites into it
tragic but it also makes you realize
okay the imitation game is now over Alan
Turing was a human the machine wouldn't
have done that
and so there's so much depth that you
can get from the movie and Andrew Hodges
as we written a great book called the
Enigma which you should make sure people
your viewers also see great biography of
Alan Turing I have a chapter on Alan
Turing and all this in my book and the
book my book the innovators ends with
something called Ada forever which is
how ADA's concept of the symbiosis
between humans and machines how that
related to Alan Turing's quest for
artificial intelligence and I find that
all very interesting but to get back to
your question the great truth of that
toring I think it conveyed in that movie
those two great truths I said but like
any movie you can say oh you know that
didn't really happen with the Soviet spy
dead good afternoon and welcome to book
TV on c-span 2 48 hours of nonfiction
books and authors every weekend and this
is our in-depth show this is where we
invite one author on to talk about his
or her body of work and this month it's
biographer author journalist Walter
Isaacson mr. Isaacson is the author of
these books first book came out in 1986
the wise men six friends in the world
they made Evan Thomas as his co-author
with that book and then in 1992
Kissinger a biography came out Ben
Franklin and American Life in 2003
Einstein his life in universe in 2007
Steve Jobs 2011 and finally the
innovators came out last year mr.
Isaacson is also the CEO of the Aspen
Institute former editor of Time former
head of CNN and a former chairman of the
broadcasting Board of Governors mr.
Isaacson
will be with us for the next three hours
so we'll put the numbers up on the
screen if you'd like to dial in and
participate in the conversation with him
here are the numbers 202 is area code 7
4 8 8200 if you live in the eastern
central time zones seven four eight
eight two zero one for those of you in
the mountain and Pacific time zones now
if you can't get through on the phone
lines and want to participate try social
media at book TV is our twitter handle
you can join the conversation on
facebook facebook.com slash book TV
you'll see right at the top of our page
there some video of mr. Isaacson that we
shared earlier this week but you can
also make a comment underneath that
video in the comment section and finally
you can send an email to book TV at
c-span Oh our G and we'll begin taking
your calls and social media comments in
just a minute we want to get through a
couple more of your books before we uh
get to calls and this is the Ben
Franklin Dan American life book and you
write that the most interesting thing
that Franklin invented and continually
reinvented was himself I love Ben
Franklin and there's a great story about
Ben Franklin in the that he tells well
he's a young tradesman and he's arrived
in Philadelphia and he's trying to be a
good civic person and so he forms a club
of people called the leather apron Club
for the working class and shopkeepers of
Market Street
and they make a list of all the values
you should have industry honestly for
gala day any marks how well he's done
and he finally masters all 12 of them II
shows them to the people in his club and
one of the people in the club says hey
Franklin you forgot a virtue you should
try and Trenton's what's that and the
princess humility you might want to on
that one for a change and Franklin which
is what I love about says I was never
very good at the virtue of humility I
never mastered it but I was very good at
the pretense of humility in other words
they could take it very well and then he
says and I learned that the pretense of
humility was just as useful as a reality
of humility because it made you listen
to the people around you made you try to
find the common ground and that was the
essence of the middle class you know
middle we the middling people democracy
that they were trying to forge and so to
me Franklin not only doing that and sort
of self-improvement which was his goal
but then writing about and doing an
autobiography in which he writes the
autobiography so we'll all know you know
the way he was that to me is why he was
constantly inventing reinventing and
then polishing his invention of himself
for history how well-known was he I mean
who can you compare him to today as far
as oh well you know he was probably one
of the best known people in the world by
the time in the world he becomes and
that well in the Western world I should
say right but by the time he becomes in
bet you know our envoi to France after
he's you know done everything from the
electricity experiments the
lightning-rod been part of the
Continental Congress helped edit the
Declaration of Independence when he goes
to France because of his writings and
because of his electricity experiment
they carry him by sedan-chair to the
steps of the Academy in Paris to meet
Voltaire the great philosopher and
Franklin you say about inventing himself
and reinventing himself and being fit PR
person
he wears a Coonskin cap and an old
backwoods coat because the people in
France have been reading Rousseau you
know probably reading was so once too
often something like this notion of the
natural philosopher from out in the wood
EPIK Franklin had never lived in the
wilderness even though the French like
all of them the American colonies or
wilderness big thing would have been
Boston Philadelphia and London but still
he takes this cap in his coat so he can
be the natural filosophy another natural
philosopher coming from this wilderness
of a country you know a land called
America to meet with the French and he
does have to play it to the help the
French love him they all make all sorts
of you know dagger you know little coins
of human you know and even in America
John Adams who was partly a friend and
partly arrival you got to read David
McCullough's wonderful book I try to do
it too in the Ben Franklin book the show
you know a lot of respect is also you
know rivalry they had but John Adams
lamented that the history of the
American Revolution will be that Ben
Franklin yo smote his you know stake on
the ground and lightning happened and
you know that he was going to get too
much clay that Ben Franklin would get
too much credit for it but I'm partial I
think Ben Franklin deserves a lot of
credit for inventing what we are as a
country when it comes to the founding
fathers with whom was he close very
close to Thomas Jefferson obviously
deficits much younger
Jefferson's a protege succeeds him as
ambassador to Paris what they
particularly shared it's back to
something we've been talking about on
this show is a belief that an educated
person should love science to love the
arts should love music should understand
botany and electricity and plans and
everything else and that was the
Enlightenment that period in which after
Sir Isaac Newton and others the laws of
science and the laws of statecraft and
the laws of how you lived your life so
two came together and I think the two
great Avatar the to grade you know icons
of the Enlightenment in America of
Benjamin Franklin in his protege Thomas
Jefferson one big difference though
Jefferson writes the first draft of the
Declaration but there's a committee to
help imagine that maybe the last time
Congress created good committee it has
been Franklin and John
on Adams and Thomas Jefferson on it
Jefferson writes we hold these truths to
be sacred Franklin takes it splinters
pain causes that's a good put
self-evident this is this notion of
science that that there's certain
logical ways that our whites come from
rationality and reason not the dictates
of a particular religion but the
sentence goes on they're endowed with
certain inalienable rights you see John
Adams putting in endowed by their
creator which certainly
so they're balancing the role of divine
providence with the role of Rights and
rationality and reason in creating our
nation and this to me is sort of you can
just see the minds of Benjamin Franklin
and Thomas Jefferson working Ben
Franklin's epitaph that he wrote himself
the body of B Franklin printer like the
cover of an old book its contents worn
out and stripped of its lettering and
gilding lies here food for worms but the
work shall not be lost for a will as he
believed appear once more in a new and
more elegant edition revised and
corrected by the author well first of
all he always considered himself a
printer I love that about Ben Franklin
even when he's the most famous person in
the world great scientist great
statesman you know leader of both the
Continental Congress and the
Constitutional Convention he still signs
himself when he goes to a lodge or
something B Franklin prenta secondly he
sort of had an amused outlook about life
and even the afterlife the very last one
of the very last letters he does when
he's dying as a Stiles president of Yale
very religious man says do you believe
in the divinity of Jesus Christ do you
believe in God the afterlife or whatever
and he had written that epitaph about yo
revives you know by the author for
better edition but he never took you
know he didn't agonize he just had a
generalized deistic feel about the
beauty of you know Lord's creation
whatever so he writes back to Ezra
Stiles he said you know I've never quite
figured that out but I'm going to find
out soon enough
meaning he was about to die so I guess
there's no need to
not worrying about it now Albert
Einstein the year 1905 why oh yeah why
was that such a big year for him you
know that's when he's a patent examiner
and the Swiss Patent Office hasn't been
able to get his PhD but he's questioning
received wisdom like Newton's wisdom
that time marches along about how we
absorb it and he's synchronizing clocks
because the Swiss had gone on standard
time zones as Swiss people as you know
of Swiss you know they lily care that
strike seven at Bern the exact same
incident strike seven and Basel or in
Zurich and so if you synchronize clocks
you got to send the signals between the
two clocks the signals travel at the
speed of light like if it's a light
signal Radio one and you got this patent
examiner saying well what if I caught up
with one of those signals wouldn't you
know the light wave seems stationary to
me what if I'm traveling to one of the
clocks really fast wouldn't what looks
synchronized be different from me
then somebody traveling really fast to
the other clock and so it comes up with
this mental leap that time is relative
depending on your state of motion speed
of light is always constant but time is
relative depending on your state of
measure so that's special relativity but
he does that exact same spring another
paper that talks about how that's
basically the fundamentals of quantum
theory that light is both a wave and a
particle that there's you know sort of
particles of light but it's also a wave
and it's a whole concept that becomes
quantum theory so you have two great
scientific theories that of the pillars
that bring us into the 20th century that
tickets from Newton's mechanics into a
new world
that's relativity and quantum theory and
both happen in the spring of 1905 while
he's sitting on a stool doing thought
experiments as a patent examiner and
that's why it's called the miracle year
for Einstein what are those things mean
to us today
pray every single great advance almost
of the 20th century has a fingerprint of
Albert Einstein on space travel the
splitting of the atom GPS you know
television even the microchip and
microprocessor when they're making the
transistor in my book the innovators you
need people know experimentally how to
fix a piece of silicon and dope it a bit
so there becomes a semiconductor in a
different way but you also need somebody
like John Bardeen a great theorist bred
Einstein you know perfectly dedicated to
understanding this quantum mechanics
that arises from Einstein's 1905 paper
that wins a Nobel Prize and people like
Shockley bill chocolate working with
them to do that and what they do is they
can envision the dance of electrons on
the surface state of a semiconducting
material based on the quantum mechanics
that comes out of einstein's paper so
whether it's a transition in the
microchip plus space travel or the GPS
in your iphone or the splitting of the
atom which by the way is not only a
scientific advance but a huge geo
political and strategic issue which is
how we use the atom bomb which is
something I sign got involved in it's
hard to think of something that makes
our life what it is today that doesn't
have a couple of the fingerprints of
Albert Einstein on it he spent his time
at Princeton but his papers are
contained at Cal State no Caltech
actually the physical papers are at
Hebrew University most of them there are
a set of comedy rissalah yeah Hebrew
University in Jerusalem which you know
even when he's dying in his deathbed he
has these 9 pages of equations we're
still trying to unify especially in a
relativity theory with quantum theory
because they don't quite reconcile he's
trying to get a unified theory and we're
going to show that formula that bedside
yeah and he just one last line of
equation so it dribbles off at the end I
went to Hebrew University because it's
just like I said I like to interview a
board and
or you know an Andy Grove when I get the
chance I love seeing the physical
document so I went to Cal Tech to go
through all of his papers wonderful
people at Cal Tech Dianna Corliss
Buckwald you know people who run the I
sign papers project but I even though
there was a copy there I felt I ought to
pay a visit you know to the shrine and
actually see the papers at Hebrew
University so I went there so that's
where the papers are and by the way
something really cool that all viewers
should do right now is starting about
two months ago
Caltech Princeton and Hebrew University
all agreed to take the papers and put
them online now so hope people will
visit Hebrew University or Caltech but
it's so cool because man we can
crowdsource understanding Einstein not
only are there all of his papers online
but the English translations so you can
read the hundreds and hundreds of
letters in 1905 if you're trying to
figure out what role did his wife this
complicated controversy what role did
his wife Mileva marriage play in the
mathematics of special relativity
we'll go read the papers go online also
see the letters he wrote to Michelle
adesso his friend who is helping them in
the Patent Office
so this excitement these days that we
can get the papers online I really
salute bad time papers project for doing
that in the toward the end of the book
he write for some people miracles serve
as evidence of God's existence for
Einstein it was the absence of miracles
that reflected divine providence yes
Einstein believed that there was a
spirit manifests in the laws of the
universe in my own book I have a whole
chapter on Einstein and God because he
wrote about it a lot he answered a lot
of questions about it but he did not
believe he believed in a a spirit
manifest and the laws of the universe in
the face of which we must be humbled and
awed and he said that's my sense of a
divine being somebody who created things
according to rules they said the amazing
thing is the universe doesn't need
didn't necessarily have to have these
elegant beautiful rules like equals
mc-squared but it does and so
understanding those rules helps you have
a sense of who God is but he did not
believe in a personal God he did not
believe in a God that if you prayed
really really long and hard would
intervene and break the laws of the
universe so that the New England
Patriots would win the Super Bowl if you
prayed hard enough or whatever you were
praying for and he said you know as that
that quote you do which is that for some
people miracles show God exists but for
me it's the elegance of the laws of the
universe and the fact that they always
hold that to me it's a miracle that to
me is spiritual so that's kind of
interesting to move to that level of
thinking I yes it's in that spirit of
immutable laws laws of deep beauty
complexity because of the the equation
for general relativity is pretty complex
but is still there and it always holds
and in some ways that's evidence of the
divine existence rather than praying for
a miracle and having a miracle happen
well we have three minutes to cover the
Cold War and Henry Kissinger before we
go to calls your Henry Kissinger book
1992 for a while after this book came
out he didn't speak to me why is that
well like the Steve Jobs book and
frankly it's I mean I think if he were
at his Nobel Peace Prize citation or his
own memoirs we play hey it doesn't do me
justice I but now he's a very funny guy
actually was at a dinner last night he
was there and I saw him would you
consider him a friend oh I would
consider him somebody I respect somebody
I find you know has a deep great sense
of World Order and how the world works
and you know I think anybody who has a
biography written about them will think
at first you know could have been more
favorable and there were things about
Kissinger I don't think he had a
fingertip feel at that time when he was
Nixon's national security adviser then
Secretary of State and with forward for
the value
and idealism that has to be an
underpinning for foreign policy in a
democratic system and so he's a great
realist or understood balances of power
but to me my fundamental criticism is
yes but we have to have a moral and even
idealistic foreign policy and those have
to be woven together so I but I do think
that you know I when I was added to of
time we invited everybody been on the
cover back and I thought I wonder if dr.
Kissinger will come back because he was
pretty annoyed and part of the book and
I got a phone call said well Walter even
the 30 Years War had end at some point
so I will come to your dinner so I you
know he has a good sense of humor and
you know you don't always have to agree
with especially these certain things
that the Nixon foreign policy did when
it came to Cambodia and dealing with the
bombing of North Vietnam and a lot of
things one could second-guess but if you
read him you feel a deep understanding
for statecraft and the creation of world
order and to speak of the Cold War he
was able to do a brilliant
out-of-the-box thinking with Nixon to
balance off Russia and China to create a
triangular diplomacy we're opening to
China and I did taunt with Russia as we
pulled out of Vietnam preserves the
influence and power in the world after a
retreat from Vietnam by doing this
triangular balance with Russia China and
to me that was a creative leap that even
the bright people the best and the
brightest the McGeorge Bundy's had
thought of earlier and that helped
preserve our influence in the world the
wisemen six friends in the world they
made Averell Harriman George Kennan
Charles Boleyn Dean Acheson Robert loved
it John McCloy were they the essence of
the establishment they were you know I
wrote that book with the friend Evan
Thomas because I was just new at Time
magazine I was coming Ronald
reagan's campaign in 1980 i think these
people handing out leaflets sort of a
the establishment the Bilderberg Group
the Rockefeller and Evan who's a friend
of mine from college you know he had
come from a more you know prep school
background said hey Evan what's this
establishment thing and then we decided
to demystify it by writing a book about
six people who were the core of the
establishment there were three
Republicans three Democrats they had a
passion you know for rising above
politics they are creative they think
out of the box because after World War
two in which Russia had been our ally
suddenly we're having to contain Russia
so they create new institutions NATO the
Marshall Plan World Bank
you know Radio Free Europe even the
Aspen Institute all created in this big
bang by these people say we have to help
win the war of ideas of economy and a
defensive struggle against Soviet backed
spread of communism
so that was thinking out of the box and
by the way today well engaging a whole
new type of struggle against you know
terrorism Islamic radical terrorists you
know and we're still using the old
institutions at the wise management
we're still trying to make NATO in the
World Bank and the IMF deal with it
I wish we were as creative as they they
were that we could think out of the box
and say what international
anti-terrorist organization should
replace NATO what should we do into the
radio for Europe to fight the you know
the hearts and minds of people around
the world so I like the creativity of
the wise men clearly it was weird to
have two very young people heaven to
myself just out of college go to a
publisher and said we want to write
about six people you've barely heard of
in a time that was far distant Sodom and
Shuster and Alice Mayhew my a Detroit
Simon Schuster said she said yeah I've
always wanted to that book and I've
always wanted to call the wise man it's
like the best and the brightest but it's
a generation before and she was able to
make that book good she was able to
untangle a pretty complicated narrative
and make it flow chronologically which
is like every book ever since then I've
ever had has been published by Simon and
she
and edited by Alice Mayhew because I
feel such a sense of loyalty that you
know they would and she would publish a
book about these statesmen nobody had
ever heard of and make it into a book
that actually made sense after we turned
in a manuscript that needed some
untangling Alice Mayhew pops up on this
on book TV quite often as the editor of
best-selling authors of nonfiction books
what is what is it about her from an
author's perspective
well she's both sees the big picture in
detail which is the essence to me of
creativity whether you're Bob Noyce or
Steve Jobs you care about each you know
the beauty of each curve and the you
know computer you're making but also
we're moving to a mobile system let's
get the iPhone that was Steve Jobs
genius that was people like Kissinger
had that as well Ben Franklin see the
big picture but also know that the devil
and God is in the details I remember the
very first chapter of the wise man and
it was trying to keep well second temper
we were trying to keep how Herman and
loved it who were you know friends of
Brown Brothers Harriman together with
Harriman and Atchison who had the Groton
school together and part of Skull and
Bones at Yale it was getting kind of
confused and she wrote a TIG de in the
margin iti was Alice's no no buts that
she says all things in good time don't
get ahead of the chronology don't get
behind it keep it chronological oh don't
don't flash forward don't have to flash
back and that was the first piece of
advice I ever got on a book and every
book I've done since then may not have
been this brilliant you know as a James
Joyce or a Faulkner who can move around
in time but I realized that in our lives
we build on the moments that happened
before and that you should keep all
things in good time you should do things
chronology chronologically you should
sort the biography with the person being
born and then with the person dying and
show how it builds up you know all
things in good time this handful of men
you write in are you quoting there
Averell Harriman in the wise men this
handful of men and a few of their close
colleague
knew that America would have to assume
the burden of a global role out of duty
and desire they heeded the call to
public service they were the original
brightest and best men whose outsized
personalities and forceful actions
brought together brought order to the
post-war chaos and left the legacy that
dominates American policy to this day
well we've spent an hour talking with
Walter Isaacson a little over an hour
and you all have been very patient and
we're going to begin taking calls emails
tweets and Facebook comments now and
we'll flash those addresses and phone
numbers up on the screen one more time
so you can get in but this is a email
from Jim Gibb in East Peoria Illinois
mr. Isaacson big fan I'm currently
reading your biography on Kissinger of
your biographies on Kissinger Franklin
Einstein and jobs who do you identify
with the most and why well Ben Franklin
and I'll leave the words of my daughter
who when she was young and I've done the
books I she said well you know all
biography is autobiography you know okay
I think Emerson said and she said when
you were writing about Ben Franklin
you're writing about yourself and I said
what do you mean
so with that - you want it to be you
know a publisher editor person who was
in the media but also cared about
diplomacy and like science and juggled a
few things and so Ben Franklin was your
idealized self I said yeah that makes
sense and then I said you know what was
I doing when I wrote about I'm saying
and she said well you're writing about
mercy cause of my father who's an
engineer a kind wonderful guy who loves
Electrical Engineering has a halo of
hair and said you know you were doing
you know because your father really
loved Einstein and you're trying to do
that said that's great and said NASA
what was I doing when I was doing
Kissinger you said oh you were writing
about a bit of your dark side Oh watch
out so when I did Steve Jobs she said I
can't quite figure out what you're doing
we needed Steve Jobs and I said yeah I
was writing about
a young person who could be a little bit
bratty a little bit you know push who
love beauty and technology but was a
kind of hard to deal with and then I
stared at her and said oh yeah you're
right the man said Donna let's let go
but I love the embankment yeah that's a
young I love Ben Franklin I think that
Ben Franklin is the one I get to talk to
some members of Congress later this week
at the Library of Congress they have a
gathering a David Rubenstein and you
know helps to put together and you know
who do you want to talk about one time
I've been Franklin then Franklin is a
person who's able to do the practicality
and holding true to values that we like
the most in this country and so I can't
say I'll ever be a Benjamin Franklin but
if I wake up every morning and say what
should I try to aspire to be you know
I've read Ben Franklin's autobiography
Matthew fully from Indianapolis email it
very much enjoyed your book on Franklin
the book is in my library had been a
number of years since I read it but I
recall you writing that during the
Revolution and the latter part of
Franklin's life there was animosity
towards Franklin from many of his peers
I recall this animosity continued past
his death and it took a number of years
before he was appreciated again yes and
this happens to everybody's reputation
in public life more so now than it was
back then just you know with all of our
media you can be torn down pretty
quickly
Franklin was somebody who was very much
a compromiser he believed that
compromises may not make great heroes
but they do make great democracies so
there were passionate people on either
side who felt you know he would be too
willing to compromise saying secondly
Franklin
you know rubbed a few people the wrong
way because just of his jovial claw
beable personality bringing people
together so you know I think I think
anybody who's powerful well respected
greatest scientist of his era great his
publisher of his era greatest diplomat
of his era one of the great statesmen
over there you're going to have people
who resisted him and he was not the most
profound of our fingers he
not Madison not Jefferson and so there
was sort of a genial surface quality
tool that I argue in the last chapter of
the book ran much deeper that that
ability to say we should all the
collegiality and working together is the
essence and what America is about
but some people felt that that was sort
of a shallow and even a Mark Twain or
others you know disparage the
autobiography of Ben Franklin you know
they have succeed how to win friends how
to influence people side of Ben Franklin
I of course think it goes deeper than
that I try to show that in my biography
of him and in Santee California
you are the first call for Walter
Isaacson yes I've been leading the
innovators and I'm trying to figure out
if there's any particular symbolism
behind the design of the cover of your
book no I wish Steve Jobs had helped
more we I wanted to show sort of
interconnected I wanted to show that
people wove together I wanted to make it
feel a bit creative but also show some
of the pictures but there was not a
grand secret design but thank you for
asking there's more people on the cover
there's a Ada Lovelace of course at the
very top Steve Jobs Bill Gates and then
Alan Turing about 30 main characters and
the innovators but those four I felt
were the ones that inspired me Phil
Portland Oregon good morning to you
you're on with Walter Isaacson good
morning thank you she spent for taking
my question
and I appreciate a mr. Walter Isaacson I
think you're a great man and I write
about great people I don't think I can
set quite as the man who in myself I
wish you a long life and is going to
keep bringing these history and icons to
us common thinking folk
first a question and just an additional
question with the server farms or cloud
computing and 3d printing you see that
as an eventual change or Industrial
Revolution to the whole world and my
second is when is Elon Musk in and talk
with you yes I see that cloud computing
3d printing mobile you know think will
have a transformative effect we're
already seeing it now which is really
since the Industrial Revolution the way
we've organized work is through firms or
corporations or whatever because you had
to be a big company to sort of have all
of the equipment you needed to
manufacture things to distribute things
to bring together the people in a
working environment to do the creativity
nowadays I think we're beginning to see
that anybody can be an on-call worker if
they want whether it's driving an uber
or designing something really cool that
stores in the cloud or uses server farms
in order to instead of having their own
big old servers and having to do there
and then 3d printing so things can be
manufactured in a tailored way back when
Lord Byron was learning about the advent
of mechanical looms he thought would we
just be putting out the same fabrics
over and over now we can go back to that
artisanal period which by which I mean
artisans get to create exactly what they
want to and instead of having it be
mass-produced and mass marketed by mass
corporations I think the notion of cloud
computing the notion of 3d printing the
notion of on-demand services will allow
people to be more entrepreneurial create
especially if we get digital currencies
that allow easier transactions and sales
online that allow people to create on
their own rather than being poor
of large industrial organizations
Richard in Palm Springs California
please go ahead with your question a
comment from Walter Isaacson
mr. Isaacson it's fascinating listening
to you and I have two questions
first of all where would you place
Steven Hawkings in the overall scheme of
things say in relation 12 at Einstein
and you mentioned the imitation game of
courses the theory of everything is also
another film about Steven Hawkings and
secondly in the imitation game and Alan
Turing was having a problem with child
dances character until his request got
to Winston Churchill and Churchill
signed off on it and I've read that
Winston Churchill loved these sort of
slightly outside the box ideas the
bouncing bomb that Barnes Wallis
invented mulberry harbour and all those
different inventions of World War two
would you talk a little bit about
Winston Churchill who I personally
regard regard as the greatest figure of
the 20th century
thank you absolutely thank you and I'm
going to actually rewind the tape a bit
because I forgot to talk about Elon Musk
as well so I'll do a LAN mosque Stephen
Hawking and Winston Churchill I did get
a chance to interview Elon Musk in fact
at a Vanity Fair Aspen Institute thing
we do in San Francisco I was on stage
with them I admire the way you on musk
is doing innovation because it's easier
to do innovation in the information
technology and digital space because
there's less regulation you can do it in
a garage or dorm room create Facebook or
Apple but doing something like cars or
batteries or rocket ships that requires
a larger degree of collaboration and a
higher degree of difficulty because I
think we sometimes have so many
regulations it's hard to innovate in
those field so his ability to think out
of the box in those fields is something
I deeply admire Stephen Hawking Stephen
Hawking you know somebody I've also
deeply admired and we wrote about and
I've spent some time dealing with the
Time magazine and what he does is he
takes and a strange thing about
Einsteins there
general relativity which Einstein was
uncomfortable with it first which is if
the equations of general relativity are
true you could have black holes well all
of a sudden even gravity you know
everything comes in on itself and like a
singularity and Stephen Hawking is the
one who's helped us understand among
many other things Stephen Hawking has
done how that works I see him as one of
the great thinkers of our time and I
love the movie about him
and finally Winston Churchill the good
thing about Churchill is he encouraged
out-of-the-box thinking he was somebody
who did indeed as the movie shows a
movie simplifies it a little bit but
when the letter comes in from Bletchley
Park saying hey we need these resources
Churchill gets it he understands how
important it is however as much as I
admire Churchill we talk about him being
the greatest figure of the 20th century
when I was at Time magazine we had to
pick the person of the century we spent
about five years doing you know
conversations working on it public event
to discuss it and it came down to four
or five people if you thought it was a
century of great you know political
struggles against communism against
Nazism fascism then you have people like
Franklin Roosevelt and Winston Churchill
stand up also is a century of civil
rights where women and blacks and
colonial people all get their own
individual rights and Gandhi or Martin
Luther King as fart of that and finally
if you think it was a century in which
Science and Technology took us to the
moon and took us to a transistor and
everything else
Einstein to me his fingerprints are on
it we ended up going with Einstein and
one thing that sort of in some ways cut
against structural as much as I admire
him was he was on the wrong side of
history when it came to colonial right
when it came to the rights of everything
from blacks and women and any of his
clash with Gandhi was Legion and in the
end the side of history was towards more
individual and civil rights and
empowerment and Churchill who was ahead
of every game when it came to fighting
communism fighting Nazism he's not he's
sort of caught behind on that one so
when we look at history we admire the
strengths of great people but we also
have to look at gee where did they turn
out not to be as right as they could
have been
how much conversation was there about
Albert Einstein getting personal in the
century well you know that's why I got
very interested in Einstein when I was
studying him to say okay personal
century and I realized there was no
biography of him written since his
papers have become available and
certainly no biography you know pure
birth to you know the end you know
chronological biography written you know
in English or by an American of
something that would som that have been
published in Germany so I realize it
would be fun to write a biography him
obviously you can probably tell from
things I've said that my vote in the end
as much as I like Churchill as much as I
like Gandhi as much as I like Franklin
Roosevelt to King my vote was for
Einstein because some centuries become
remembered you know maybe five six ten
centuries from now will be remembered
for their huge advances in science the
fact that we went to the moon the fact
that we invented the microchip the
computer the transistor the internet
that we had an entire new revolution
that was based on digital technology on
splitting the atom on the way electrons
dance on surface states of
semiconducting material all of that
creates a revolution just like the 18th
century with Benjamin Franklin and
Thomas Jefferson and John Maynard Keynes
and others was a century of statecraft
you know in revolution that was
political and just as other centuries
will be remembered for other things so I
came down on the side of Einstein and
you're the editor at the time so you're
always counted I love it yeah well I
took a balance but we went up to Hyde
Park I certainly went to Churchill war
rooms in England we had fun exploring
all of this I read all of Gandhi I went
to South Africa to look you know what
Gandhi had started I love to soak myself
into the history of that field and
there's a great debate there's obviously
no right answer
I mean that's why it's an interesting
and I kept saying you know Steve Jobs
would say the journey is a reward
meaning it says the destination is not
so much
Einstein the destinations being on board
the ability to talk it through and we
did for two years in our magazines have
people talk through what matters what
will matter a century from now what will
matter ten centuries from now and you
could come down on Churchill or Franklin
and be just as right but the
conversation about it was really a fun
one to have Bernie in Howard Beach New
York you are on with Walter Isaacson on
book TV Thank You miss Isaacs and I
enjoyed the Kissinger book very much I
haven't seen the Turing film I'd like
you to help me out
I know basically the geometry of the
Enigma machines it's an electronic and
mechanical device so two people want to
communicate so the one who wants to send
the message use the his enigma machines
to put the message in a cypher correct
and the one who wants to decipher needs
the identical machine with the identical
settings to decipher it and what happens
is and this is the Enigma machine the
code changes each day for how you
decipher it so they only have and they
show this in the movie 24 hours to be
able to break exactly
you know what the deciphering in other
words that the letter W in the code
actually refers to the letter P or
something and there were multiple rotors
so it's very difficult to break the code
for which letter said for what there are
a few things that help them is that part
of the Enigma process was no letter
could stand for itself so W couldn't be
representative of W but it was still
very hard to break until they realized
that there were certain phrases that
they could use now one thing the movie
does not show fully that I think is
important is that the end
making the enigma code done by something
called the bomb the OMB II was an
electromechanical device with lots of
rotors in the movie they also show him
building a electronic device one that
uses vacuum tubes and that was called
Colossus
there was not an electromechanical
device it was a device that uses
electronic circuits to do it and that
was something that wasn't really built
by Alan Turing even though his ideas and
he was part of the whole Bletchley Park
team his ideas were used on it there
were many people like Max Newman who was
Touring's professor at Cambridge who
helped do it so it's good to read I hope
the Andrew Hodges enigma book or if you
want a shorter version read the chapter
in my book the innovators that talks
about how Colossus which is really one
of the first all-electronic computers
was built Nancy is in LaGrange Georgia
I'm Nancy hi thank you good afternoon
it's a great honor to speak with mr.
Isaacson I call to ask if he is aware of
James Lovelock Gaia hypothesis but it
relates to the discussion he had about
Franklin and Voltaire and I wondered if
he's aware of Voltaire's Tyria
spontaneous generation and now that was
debated with Jefferson and Franklin and
dr. Richard price as a young British
Unitarian minister who said the purpose
of miracles is to prevent the need for
miracles Nancy why why is this of
interest you because of the fossil water
in the Ogallala Aquifer the water is
that the debate between the American
Philosophical society that Voltaire's
theory of spontaneous generation was
because of seashells being in the Andes
and Jefferson didn't think that it was
mere it was a miracle they did this
before plate tectonics and discovery of
plate tectonics and I'm concerned about
protecting the water in the Ogallala
Aquifer which was put down in the last
ice age ten to twelve thousand years ago
and I think that we're living as a
similar time nail and
James Lovelock British biologists and
ecologists has posited that the that the
earth the name for the earth is Gaia and
so he thinks we have developed these
communications systems which I can't use
I have photosensitive everything to keep
component ourselves arrange and protect
the earth all right Nancy we're going to
leave it there well yeah I think that if
you look at Einstein Jefferson to
Franklin they were very much empiricists
and they were right when it comes to by
the fossils with area Leonardo da Vinci
figures that out too that is not just
miracles
there's natural explanations and I think
the important thing in life is not to
debunk natural explanations but try to
appreciate the beauty of natural
explanations for example on a very
similar thing there was something met
you know we should use the word
mesmerized well there was something
mesma was actually a real person to
believe that magnetized trees could cure
diseases and the French King asked Ben
Franklin to do a test is that you know
is Mesmer right can you have this sort
of you know magnetic forces that are
supernatural and Franklin just does a
controlled study doesn't tell people
which trees will quote mesmerized and
which ones want and says now there's a
natural explanation it's not some
strange mystery so I think although we
can appreciate the beauty of life we
should always look for natural
explanations Rob is in Fairfield
Connecticut hi Robbie
hi Peter I hope you and mr. Isaacson
will find it amusing that my
nine-year-old niece Mikayla and my
seven-year-old nephew Brendan are
constantly debating about what's more
boring when uncle Robbie comes over to
watch book TV or their father watches
golf but my question to you mr. Isaacson
is in regards to I am a secular agnostic
European American and for the life of me
I can't figure out how the Martin Luther
King or other social leaders have
impacted my life
positively one-half of 1% and I just
wonder if you think if you could comment
if we as a country perhaps because of
guilt plays an inordinate amount of
import on social leaders as opposed to
the onus rocks the Henry Ford's the
Steve Jobs the Bill Gates and I'm
ashamed to say I don't know the man or
the woman or the men and the women who
created chemotherapy and radiation so
I've heard versus you know what I was
that you comment on that sure when I was
in Time magazine you know I did feel
that political leaders social leaders
they always got on the cover of Time but
it was odd that the person who invented
television whether it be he's looking to
Philo Farnsworth you can debate how is
that that was never a cover of Time or
the people ed so that's why I wanted to
make Andy Grove when he was running
Intel in the microchip
you know man here or David Howe who
created you know medical treatments
involved aids and combination therapies
or the people who sequence the genome
because to me these people are as
important in affecting our lives so you
know when we were looking for person of
the century as I described you have to
look at great political and social
leaders you have to look at great
scientific leaders as well as well as
great you know political and military
leaders all play a part
but in my writings especially after I
did Ben Franklin who I began writing
about as a diplomat and statecraft ER
and then I was oh he was a really good
scientist I realize that we also have to
look at the scientists and technologists
and engineers the internet and the
computer are the two most important
inventions of our time they're changing
our lives more than most any other thing
that's happening and yet most people do
not know who invented them so my book
the innovators it says here's how the
computer was invented here the people
you also think for that likewise how the
internet or search engines or whatever
it is was invented so I think it's
important to celebrate those people as
much as we might celebrate a political
leader or you know a social leader
Bonnie Lincoln
Myers Florida email you say that one of
your strengths as a biographer is your
ability to listen I'm curious how did
you listen to Ben Franklin and Albert
Einstein the great thing about Benjamin
Franklin and Albert Einstein you say
what letters every single day as I said
earlier you go online and just you know
search Einstein papers project and
you'll see every letter he wrote you
know dozens in a given day and the
papers he wrote and so if you go
chronologically and back then before was
online I got to the Sterling library at
Yale and just go through page after page
of his papers Benjamin Franklin and then
they were published you feel he's
writing a letter to his son that he
writes to his sister Jane Meachem then
he waits a particular pamphlet or part
of Poor Richard's Almanack and you see
how this happened so in some ways having
that conversation or if you look at
later on Leonardo da Vinci and all the
notebooks he left that's part of a
conversation - I worry about the fact
that in this day and age
we're not leaving a lot of letters in
the archives we're having writing emails
but they kind of disappear after 20
years we're not writing great notebooks
the journals or Diaries the way the
people in the wise men did so
conversations happen not just by envious
now one thing I learned writing by
kissing dirt the wise men and others you
read the documents they'll tell you one
thing and I'll give you a part of the
picture then you interview the people
and say oh yeah well I wrote that letter
but here's the real reason I wrote it -
Harriman it wasn't or here's a real
reason that memo of that conversation
with Henry Kissinger was that way so it
helps to be able to combine archival
research with old-fashioned journalistic
interviews and as I said I may not be
the best journalist and I'm certainly
not the best archival historian but I
was able and have been able I hope to
combine the two to read the documents
and then do the interviews Hakeem is in
San Jose California hiakim hello thank
you for taking my call something very
insightful that mr. Isaacson you said we
need to rethink in
tuition such as NATO and think outside
box for current day applications I used
to volunteer with the late Doug Franco
James Franco's father and he would say
we would do orphaned development
projects and high-conflict rural areas
and you would often say orphan
development is the front line on the war
on terror what are your thoughts about
these types of approaches towards
leading with peace initiatives
absolutely NATO and by the way we did
that at the beginning of the Cold War we
didn't just create NATO we did the
International Monetary Fund in the World
Bank but also all sorts of social
organizations around the world World
Health Organization's development group
and UN Development Project at the Aspen
Institute we have a Middle East
investment initiative for example that
helps Palestinians and others in the
Muslim world create small businesses
often with loan guarantees or loans from
the bank leumi or other Israeli banks so
that you get people working together
this is something Benjamin Franklin
understood in Philadelphia wasn't just
about big organizations it was about
people getting together form you know
civic sweeping cores or militia or a
lending library that could be done that
way I think as we fight this new global
struggle
it really helps I just met two Desmond
Hammond who is dr. Susman Hammond who's
a new head of the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation the development work that the
Gates Foundation is doing on world
health the type of things I hope we at
the Aspen Institute are doing on
creating you know empowerment of people
around the world through nongovernmental
organizations I think that's part of the
forefront of winning a war that demands
we win both hearts and minds and the
loyalties of people feeling there's an
opportunity in this world that I can be
a part of what is he Aspen Institute
yesBut Institute is a sort of like a
think-tank we have 30 policy
organizations that look at everything
from education reform to relations with
Russia to you know strategy groups arms
control environment energy
it's also a Leadership Institute well we
have a young leaders programs around the
world starting you know it's about a
dozen in the United States and different
fields we bring young leaders together
to try to come to common ground based on
pragmatic fact-based you know things to
be nonpartisan and whether it's our
Rodell program that has half Democrats
half Republicans working together in
projects of people who are elected
officials or Henry clown program who
bring entrepreneurs and business leaders
together to find sensible solutions to
our problems we try to turn thought into
action so it's basically a think-tank
in which we groom young leaders to turn
thought into action
founded in 1949 by it by a group of
Chicago industrialists and you know one
of the earlier questions is about
talking about don't you like scientists
technologists engineers as well as
political leaders we also have to
realize that like Steve Jobs and others
industrialists business leaders people
like Bob Noyce who is both an engineer
but helped start Intel that is good to
look at the business and entrepreneurial
community - when we look at things so
there were these entrepreneurs and
business leaders in Chicago in nineteen
eight 1940s who realize that at the
beginning of the Cold War you not only
needed NATO you not only needed a World
Bank International Monetary Fund but you
needed think tanks that would look at
democratic values the values of free
minds and free markets and figure out
how those would help make a better world
and that group of business leaders led
by Walter Papke who in Container
Corporation of America
Henry clown of the clown family there
they helped create an institute that
would look at our values and how they
could you know help shape a better world
how'd you get the main it has a campus
in Aspen Colorado which is useful and
confuses people because we're in
Washington doing this show our
headquarters is actually in Washington
the one of the glories one of the
hundreds of glories of being part of the
Aspen Institute is that when it gets
really hot in Washington and June July
August most of our programs are done on
a campus in Colorado and Aspen Walter
Isaacson
is the CEO of the Aspen Institute he's
also an author and biographer and we've
got a little over an hour to go with our
guests but every guest who's on in depth
we ask what they're reading some of
their influences here's a look at mr.
Isaacson's answers
[Music]
Walter Isaacson who is Walker Percy he
was one of my original heroes mentor
uncle of a friend of mine being a
funcle' by marriage one of those things
we call him uncle Walker
we should go across Lake Pontchartrain
from New Orleans where I grew up and we
go fishing on the Booga falaya which is
a lazy river over there and and Percy
was a friend of ours and we couldn't
figure out what her dad did you know he
was always at home drinking bourbon neat
and hog head cheese so you say what's
your dad do like he's a writer and it
wasn't till the movie Goa came out but
in the early 1960s and I was 9 or 10
years old that was Oh a writer that's
something you can be when you grow up
just like a fisherman or an engineer or
doctor or whatever and I took sort of an
interest in you know dr. Percy
uncle Wonka and you know I would sit
down I'd sort of read his books and say
well they're sort of deep philosophical
religious messages especially in the
movie go or the last gentleman and I
asked him about that and he'd say things
like you know Walter two types of people
come out of Louisiana preachers and
storytellers he said the guy take be a
storyteller the world's got too many
preachers so you wouldn't answer my
questions he'd say do it through the
story you know the way the Bible does it
which is not just Commandments it's
storytelling when he said the
storytelling is the most effective way
to get across the type of things you are
interested in so he became somebody I
deeply deeply admired and of course
every couple of years I just reread the
moviegoer which is one of the greatest
books of all time well you list another
New Orleans connected writer somebody
you're currently reading they get Dave
Eggers he's New Orleans connected is me
well he came down after the snow woman
you know if you're from New Orleans you
you say to yourself I'll judge people by
what they did after the levees broke
after Katrina and David have a good
Eggers comes down he writes a great book
that involves I was a tune one of the
characters coming out of the hurricane
but I admired Dave Eggers who's not from
New Orleans well before the hurricane
when I was at Time magazine I remember
he
went to Cuba for us once I think the
bicycle around Cuba and report on it and
then when his book heartbreaking a
heartbreaking work of staggering genius
came out about his helping to raise his
brother Tov after his parents died it
was like wow of a voice our generation
can relate to so if I had to pick novels
including the circle hologram for the
King the SoCo came out bit of a warning
about the privacy and personal issues
that come from overuse of Technology
over reliance on the digital revolution
those of us who love the digital
revolution have two or three devices at
all times and watch you follow a Twitter
feed it's like that's great but it's
good to read a novel like the circle
that says okay let's take a little bit
more detached view of all this which I
like to grow up in New Orleans but what
is it about Nora
New Orleans has a creativity that comes
from a diversity of people when Ben
Franklin runs away from Boston gets to
Philadelphia goes well there's more
Ravens and Quakers and Anglicans and
Jews and Episcopalians and slaves of
freed slaves and that makes for
creativity New Orleans you had that you
know triple fold you had or in my
neighborhood of Broadmoor in Central
City right in the heart of the city the
very mixed neighborhood mix economically
mixed racially mixed ethnically and you
realize the same neighborhood that a
hundred years before Louis Armstrong he
had grown up in that neighborhood near
perdido Street you know one of the great
sort of central streets in New Orleans
and Louis Armstrong growing up there is
influenced by you know the great French
opera singers and also the slaves coming
back from the plantation singing you
know spirituals but also the sanctified
Church people coming back from the
spanish-american war and Hawking their
corn nets at the pawn shop so that the
karnovski family a Jewish family who
lived in that neighborhood could help
him get a horn out of hock inside
playing the trumpet he's put in the wave
song because you know he's complicated
family life and but you see in that
diversity what do you get you get jazz
he's here playing West End blues with
King Oliver kid ory all the great jet
having heard Buddy Bolden and all of a
sudden he's doing
vodka Denzel RIF to open western blues
that you say whoa where did that come
from what comes from being too exposed
to a diversity of interests and talent
and musical influences and that's also
true the food of New Orleans I just came
back my wife and I you know we go quiet
off and just came back last week and
just looking at the creativity of
restaurants of the architecture you say
okay I didn't think that the city would
come back after the storm it's been 10
years now we've been creative about the
school system creative about a a
entrepreneurial economy places like idea
village that Tim Williamson started
there which is an incubator for cool
people who just want to do quit and I
think that the next wave of
entrepreneurship and innovation that's
not just from information technology or
digital technology but connecting the
creative industries and arts to digital
technology theater that becomes
immersive and interactive things that
you know who knows food music new forms
of it that we can do when we connect
creative arts to technology I see that
happening in New Orleans as well phone
lines are all jammed we'll put the
numbers up just in case and we'll also
put up our social media addresses if you
want to get in and talk with Walter
Isaacson Ben Franklin the Autobiography
one great moral issue historians must
wrestle with when assessing America's
founders is slavery mm-hmm and Franklin
was wrestling with it as well
slaves made up about 6% of
Philadelphia's population at the time
and Franklin had facilitated the buying
and selling of them through ads in his
newspaper yep in the Pennsylvania
Gazette when he first started it you can
see ads for buying and selling of slaves
he even owned Ben Franklin did two
household slaves and when you look at
Jefferson who was a big slave owner
that's what you gotta wrestle with the
thing with the Ben Franklin bookends and
his life ends is that everybody makes
deep moral mistakes at times I said that
Ben Franklin's strength was that he knew
how to compromise
eyes knew how to you know at the
Constitutional Convention as he said
shave a little from one side of the
joint and another until you had a good a
piece of wood that would hold together
for centuries he compromises on slavery
as they do in the Constitution and he
realizes it's a deep flaw a mistake he
had made because he's introspective
that's what we all have to learn is gee
I know some mistakes I've made you know
neither my greatness normal mistakes as
half as high or low as Ben Franklin but
he did that from the very beginning of
his life he kept a ledger and I mean a
real one where he made a chart of every
errata he called it Arata meaning error
a mistake a moral mistake that he made
and then on the right hand side how he
had rectified it so for example I think
it begins with running away from his
brothers print shop in Boston because he
was apprenticed to his brother James and
he was not allowed to leave you when you
had signed an apprenticeship you had to
say throughout before you could leave he
runs away secretly because he doesn't
want to work for his brother James he
calls that an error a lapse a moral
lapse he rectifies it when James dies he
Benjamin Franklin provides for the
education of James's kids so that's his
way of keeping a moral ledger but at the
very end there's a big one it tolerated
and compromised on slavery now of course
he frees his slaves and of course he
feels this as an era but very old late
in life I think it was about 80 he
becomes a president of the Society for
the abolition of slavery and his last
great peace he always wrote hoaxes and
jokes and parodies was a piece called
the speech by the divan of Algiers which
was about a leader in Algiers explaining
why he was putting white Europeans that
they captured into slavery in Algiers
and it was parodying all the argument
but also widiculous a brutal peace
against the arguments that were being
made in Congress to justify slavery so
this is how he tries to rectify a deep
moral error and when you get to the
compare and contrast Franklin and
Jefferson
you know Jefferson never quite gets it
now Jefferson from Virginia Franklin's
from Pennsylvania maybe it's a little
easier but still as good as brilliant as
Jefferson was he doesn't get to that
same moral place that Ben Franklin does
of being appalled that he had compromise
on the issue of slavery and tries to
rectify it by being president of the
Society for the abolition wisemen
co-author Evan Thomas came out in 1986
kissinger biography 1992 benjamin
franklin an american life oh three
einstein in oh seven steve jobs 2011
Walter Isaacson's most recent book is
the innovators how a group of hackers
geniuses and Geeks created the digital
revolution somebody's going to buy one
of your books wants to read it which one
do you suggest you know nowadays I we
talk about Ben Franklin being the person
I would like to the most if you want to
sort of understand the role you can play
in your civic life and in pulling people
together you know when I graduated from
college I don't remember who my
graduation speaker was but there was a
minister in the Memorial Church and he
gave a sermon the last day called what
we forgot to tell you and he said what
we forgot to tell you is we told you
that this was an exclusive college and
you got into classes that were very
exclusive in public clubs that were
exclusive but what we forgot to tell you
is that life is about inclusion not
exclusion and you will be judged by how
many people you bring together not how
many people you exclude that was a point
of Ben Franklin's life somebody who was
able to break people different races
creeds together into a sense of civic
you know community and so to me that's
still the most important lesson you know
during his lifetime he donated to the
building fund of each and every church
that was built in Philadelphia and at
one point they were building a new Hall
right next to Independence Hall for
wayward you know wandering preachers of
the great and awakening and so he makes
a fundraising document he says even if
the mufti of Constantinople would it
send somebody here to preach Islam to us
and teach us about the Prophet
but we should offer a pulpit and we
should listen fully might work and on
his deathbed he's the largest individual
contributor to the mikveh Israel
synagogue or synagogue and filled up so
when he dies instead of his minister
accompanying his casket to grave all 35
preachers priests and ministers only
gone to the rabbi of the Jews and March
with him to get that was the secret
sauce of the nation we were creating
back then one of inclusion and that's
what we're still fighting for whether it
be in Paris in Syria in Ferguson today
is and so to me he's the inspiring of
how do you live your life obviously
Einstein if you want to understand the
beauty the spiritual beauty of the
elegance of the laws that are manifest
in the universe that manifests itself in
the universe I join and Steve Jobs if
you want to know how to really make a
dent in that universe by having a
passion for making beautiful products at
Steve Jobs so obviously like your kids
you like all the books but there's a
certain partiality you're going to say
how can I make my little world a better
place I talk about reading Ben Franklin
what's your next book you know I've
always been that two books on juggling
with and maybe people can buy Twitter
tell me what to do I really like this
notion I talk about of New Orleans where
diverse strands and people come together
and that's how creativity occurs like
Ben Franklin would want when we respect
different size you get jazz or whatever
and to me the tale of Louis Armstrong's
life is a tale of creativity born of a
love for different influences and
diversity and it's a life of the Arts
but just connected to a lot more I've
trouble I've studied Armstrong as I say
I go I played jazz going up so I played
jazz with some people who played jazz
with Louis Armstrong so you kind of feel
a kinship but I'm still not sure I fully
understand whether it's happy why would
you know so I'm not sure that the other
which is going into the Wayback Machine
for a while would be the ultimate
connection of
to engineering the ultimate connection
the person with science in the person of
the humanities and that of course is
Leonardo da Vinci who's Vitruvian Man
you know the the man in the circle
that's the symbol of the connection that
we in my mind the symbol the connection
between the arts and the sciences and
that to me is such any less so many
notebooks and so many drawings that
geeking out on those notebooks and
seeing how he thought of himself as an
engineer and he did you know autopsies
and you know Anatomy on cadavers but how
that's reflected in each of the
paintings he does to me that's an
exciting thing to well we just learned
Walter Isaacson is writing two books
Renato DaVinci and one on New Orleans
and Louis Armstrong Cathy in Etna
Wyoming you have been very patient
please go ahead
thank you mr. Isaacson Henry Kissinger
came to a security meeting before the
People's Congress this past week and
many individuals were protesting holding
up signs shouting out his warmongering
past and interrupting them and not
surprisingly John McCain called the
protesters lowlife scum while demanding
their removal I think activists are some
of the greatest people of our time do
you see this protest is did you see this
protest and do you have any comments
about it and what do you think about non
prosecution of war mongers thank you
sure I obviously saw it on TV I was not
sending there I think that the ability
you know starting with people like
Thomas Paine to people today in our
society to protest and have free speech
and our comfort with protest and free
speech that makes us a stronger Society
and you look at societies like China
where the free flow of information or
protest free flow of ideas is too much
repressed and central never be
successful in the digital age I do think
that that was an unfortunate approach to
protest and we certainly have better
ways to make us we then sort of making a
piece of dumb in my mind theater
against you know George Shultz Madeleine
Albright Henry Kissinger sitting there I
think that there ways to express and
study one's feeling about kissinger's
decisions I do not think he was a
warmonger
but even if I did I would hope I would
find a better way to try to convince
others of that than doing that I think
not very useful bit of theater and I did
it you know I did admire and read the
testimony of Henry Kissinger and if
you're looking for books to read and you
want to understand Kissinger where he's
really coming from we'd world order it's
a great book that came out last year you
may say well he's a war monger is they
know here's a structure of thought that
leads to his sense of what makes for a
stable good order and you can disagree
with it but then push back
intellectually instead of the thing that
I found kind of disturbing David is
calling in from st. Thomas Virgin
Islands David you're on with Walter
Isaacson mr. Isaacson I am a new fan
since I saw you on book TV the other day
if you'll indulge me for a moment I'd
like to make a quick comment to our
friends in Connecticut scientists create
technology social leaders and artists
teach us what to do with the technology
I'd like to go on my question I feel
much least the last several millennia of
human history has been about the
evolution of power from to print more to
individuals as we become more thoroughly
interfaced with our technology as we
move towards becoming cyborgs I guess
how do we protect ourselves from losing
our individual uniqueness in that
process I think you answered your
question in the very beginning of your
statement which is it's a humanities in
the arts that make us unique one of the
things about that Alan Turing movie is
as much as we thought we would like
machines that we could be cyborgs in the
end
human in the end he has his own
creativity until the end of the
innovators is a chapter about this I
also didn't electro for the National
Endowment on humanities of Jefferson
lecture last year which is the
importance of connecting the humanities
to the sciences
why because it's about the importance of
connecting our humaneness to our
machines instead of letting our machines
sort of run away without us a lot of
people fearing artificial intelligence
singularity the robots taking over but
as long as we understand our connection
our interfacing with our machines
I think our creativity our art our moral
sensibilities those are the things we
have done Zen to understand a moral and
aesthetic sensibility it really helps
understand history the humanities and
the arts Attila
Attila Bay posts on our Facebook page of
your books which do you find teaches
most about learning about culture or a
culture
well the Benjamin Franklin invents a new
form of culture a culture in which
there's a tolerance of people different
religions backgrounds ethnic groups to
create a democracy based on individual
liberty that also has a spirit of
community to it that's one of the
strands of America I don't even think
Tocqueville didn't fully get it right he
thought you know our forming of
associations was in conflict with our
individuality Ben Franklin knew that our
individuality and our ability to come
together to form militias and
street-sweeping cords and libraries and
hospitals that was a core of a new form
of culture but to me the I if I'd enter
in another way the very interesting
cultural situation is when Einstein is
in Germany wrestling with general
relativity that comes after the 1905
miracle of special relativity he now
wants to tie gravity into it he wants to
make a way to tie in the whole forces of
the universe and have a theory of
gravity that relates to even space and
time the grand
just and most elegant of all theories
but he's doing it in Germany as a Jew
when anti-semitism is rising he's a
member of the Prussian Academy but he's
gotten as he split from his wife he's
being ostracized more and more by
attacks on what is called Jewish science
and so watching that drama as from 1914
to 1915 with 100th anniversary now of
general relativity which is 1915 as I
say the most elegant theory in my mind
of all of science as he marches to that
great theory with his huge social forces
sort of pushing in on him racing to get
that theory right to me that's the most
dramatic period this summer of 1915 when
all of this is happening in Germany all
of this is happening in Europe and he's
trying to figure out the spirit manifest
in the laws of the universe another
Facebook comment this is from Preetha
being in the field of science education
both as an educator and researcher I'm
always puzzled how little emphases are
is placed on history and philosophy of
science innovations in primary and
secondary school education what are your
thoughts on this issue and how that
might help students pursue science I
think it's a great question because I've
become come to believe that one of the
best ways to teach science and to teach
the humanities is through the history of
science starting with the Scientific
Revolution starting with Galileo Kepler
and others as they start doing
experiments and they test certain
theories and Copernicus comes along and
those series conflict with our religious
convictions maybe that you know the Sun
will do you know revolves around the
earth as apposed system or whatever and
then seeing how the scientific method
has progressed all the way through helps
teach us how to think helps teach us as
society progresses but also teaches us
how to combine an appreciation for the
humanities for that matter
religion art whatever you know is
particularly important to you how they
gets reconciled with science my daughter
I mentioned earlier goes off to college
she's trying to figure out what to major
in the college she goes who has a great
history of science department and she
emailed me said I didn't know science
had a history but now that I look at the
history of science I see how we build on
things and how there is a method that
then as I'd said about Benjamin Franklin
and Thomas Jefferson can be transferred
to how we make a constitution how we
make a democratic system how we make a
society so I think an appreciation for
the history of science is something that
our society you know to grab onto more
and it may be the coolest way to teach
you know we do teach physics we teach
biology whatever but if you want to
understand where biology is going and
where it came from
we've the double helix by Watson and
Crick that wonderful you know rushing
into the Eagle pub in Cambridge having
decoded the DNA and announcing it to the
other people in the pub that gives you
an excitement of science but it also
helps you figure out how human
creativity can decode the structure of
DNA
you've mentioned bets in your daughter
who introduced you to Ada of Lovelace
and be also uh in all of your books
mentioned a woman named Kathy oh my wife
yeah well you know she's got the most
common sense of anybody and she is the
first and last reader of every book you
know when I do the first draft and
before I turn in the last draft and you
know there's a when you connect the
humanities Kathy somebody under here
she's been a lawyer but she walks on the
Washington Women's Foundation New York
Women's Foundation helping other people
that notion of being engaged in society
is always helpful when you're trying to
write a biography and say well how will
that connect other people in society
ium Facebook comment in the wisemen you
write about the American establishment
is there an establishment mentality
today if so what is it in your opinion
who or what determines those within this
establishment yeah there is an
establishment
leti and i mean that neither to elevate
it nor to denigrate it there is a
general consensus that I would call
merely habit some of the Aspen Institute
the Aspen Strategy Group our Aspen
Strategy Group is run by Brent Scowcroft
who was George Bush the Elders national
security value and Joe Nye is a great
professor at Harvard and in a democratic
administration and so but likewise
Council on Foreign Relations the various
sort of established view of the world
which believes in free minds free
markets a liberal democracy it believes
in balancing a realist view of foreign
policy meaning what are our national
interests and say if we're going to talk
about Ukraine and Russia is this the
best place to assert it is our balance
we can do with Russia how do we get out
of this with an idealistic approach to
foreign policy which is we want a
democracy we want we want to fight
against people who are tyrannical so
that wrestling with a balance between
idealism and realism and with
intervention ISM versus a humble foreign
policy you can see that happening in the
American establishment the good thing
about the United States is the
establishment is always being challenged
so whether it's you know a Ted Cruz or
you know a Rand Paul in the Republican
Party or in the Democratic Party people
who are more against the general
consensus that led us to a lot of
interventions some of which I thought
were misguided in the past 15 years
including in my opinion that may be
wrong
you know the invasion of Iraq I thought
was a misguided and ended up being
miscalculated but also not thought
through enough so challenging the
establishment view by the way the
American foreign policy establishment
from Democrats and Republicans would
generally in favor the invasion of Iraq
that was a mistake
so that says hey we need Outsiders who
are going to challenge that view say
what are we thinking why are we getting
into this so the balance between an
establishment view
which the wisemen represented in the
late 1940s and the outsiders this is why
democracy tends to be so much better
even as one of my criticism of Henry
Kissinger
he doesn't realize that's his strength
of democracy when people from the
outside get to challenge you and get to
say no what are you doing why are you
going into Cambodia or Vietnam or the
sea no those type of things that to me
makes them a democracy stronger at
waging foreign policy the wise men of
the six Olin Peron atoms and how many
did you get a talked well George Kennan
very much so Kip Boland was no longer
alive spent a lot of time with John
McCloy who was you know died right as a
book came out but he gave great names
likewise with Averill Harriman and I
remember near the very end as we were
finishing the book Pamela Harriman his
wife would let us come sit by governor
Harriman's bed and talk to him about
things and when Evan and I were doing in
love sak loved it mccloy Harriman and
kennen I got to speak to Boland and
Atchison had both died obviously I
talked to a lot of Bowen and actresses
children and colleagues but working with
Evan Thomas my co-author on that book we
were both journalists once again it was
a it was a chance to look at archives
look at all the letters Atchison I'm
sorry Harriman and love it and we'll
both the Brown Brothers Harriman when
loved it and then Harriman then go into
government wrote each other twice a day
so you got the conversation in the
letters but then you could go to
governor Harriman and say okay what did
you mean about you know this thing on
Laos when you were to love it and so one
of the things Evan and I were able to do
in writing that book was combine the
ability to go to the archives New York
Historical Society had the Brown
Brothers Harriman archives kennen's
archives when the five-seven library
printed but also then go to the people
and say who were involved and say when
you got that letter what were you really
aiming at and so that's why I like this
intersection that I've been able to be
part of between a journalistic approach
to
three and a a archival academic approach
to history are we losing some of that
with today's technology of really a
because often people email a couple
times a day a couple never knew is that
blood I remember sitting in Steve Jobs's
house I said what about the emails when
you were first coming back to Apple
1997-98 hugely dramatic period you
didn't write letters you didn't keep a
journal
your memories pretty good but you know
all memories of bed may be yours you
know whatever he said when I got those
emails and there was a next computer
because he was working in the company
had sound to call next he had it in his
house and he and also two techies tried
to figure out how do we get access to
these emails that were composed on a
UNIX based next operating system and he
couldn't even get those emails so I
sometimes talk to archivists nowadays we
did something at Harvard with a history
of the digital age that john huey paul
sagan my innocent Holtz and others did
which is to try to get oral histories
but also get people's emails I went back
to my emails from the early 1990s and
after four or five techies helped me I
found all the emails when I was running
digital media for Time Inc and we were
arguing with CBS and you know trying to
create Pathfinder and Roadrunner and
broadband system I said here's all my
emails but I would hope that university
libraries when they get the papers of
Bill Gates they get the papers of author
lock let's say who started venture
capital in the West Coast then they say
we not only need your papers but give us
all your old computers we want to save
your emails because I worry that we're
not archiving emails very well I just
went an unbelievably good piece of this
last night by Jill Lepore in The New
Yorker this week's issue of The New
Yorker about the Internet Archive which
I've always admired but never quite knew
how it really worked and these are
people who are in San Francisco but now
in consortiums around the world
archiving every you know you look at
your Twitter feed look when Twitter is
affecting
the events in Ferguson of the immense
entire square how are we going to get
those tweets fifty years from now when
we're writing about what really happened
entire score of Ferguson how we can get
those emails how we can get those
Facebook pages how we going to get even
the you know web pages that somebody may
have put up but it's 50 years from now
and God knows where they are so I think
we have to have a real effort to archive
people's emails voluntarily I mean you
sound like the NSA may be archiving our
emails when we don't want them to but I
mean if you're donating your papers and
you're Bill Gates make sure your emails
a part of it and if we're trying to
archive all the newspapers
let's also archive the Twitter where
Twitter is doing that now but Facebook
and all the web pages people should read
Jill Lepore piece in this week's New
York on Internet Archive and of course
Jill deport was a National Book finalist
I think last year for her biography on
Jane Frankland Jane me go stir the CI
Jane the sister of Ben Franklin and this
is the cool thing they wrote letters all
the time so you have the letters Ben
Franklin is writing verge on the French
Foreign Minister but you also have the
letters he's writing Jane talking about
you know what he's doing and of course
that's a different conversation and it's
great the way she has tried to create a
biography even though we don't know much
about Jane but create a biography that
is based on the letters to her brother
and from a brother Elizabeth and
willoughby Ohio you've been very patient
your honor Walter Isaacson thank you
well first of all you have to do
invaders Park oh um I really there's a
lot of information that you have been
covering in in invaders that I really am
looking forward to reading about
especially the women in IP but having
studied in ite I know it's really hard
for us to get into it first of all but
then the second thing is maybe I would
like to see that book on DaVinci because
after taking a math class and IT classes
and
our class sometimes all at the same time
I'm beginning to understand we don't
understand the interaction between the
arts music and and engineering and the
other half of our lives
absolutely and when Mozart is I mean
when Einstein is trying to do general
relativity as I described before in
1914-15 and all things hell is breaking
loose he pulls out his violin and plays
Mozart as he paces up and down his
cortman
because he believes that Mozart scored
to help them connect with the harmonies
of the universe Ben Franklin is that way
Ada Lovelace as I said earlier is great
to connecting art to science
Leonardo is greatest but you get back to
part two of the innovators I mean one
you know problem with the innovators and
criticism of it is every day I get four
or five letters saying you left out you
know Seymour Cray or you left out you
know the people who did basic you know
at Dartmouth or whatever I would like to
someday have a multimedia crowd-sourced
open-source book maybe with a digital
royalties system so I can share in the
royalties in which people take a book
like the innovators and that's there you
know as the foundation but they write
other chapters like women's that they
put on they say you know here's what
happened in Bell Labs or Xerox PARC or
here's what happened you know with this
innovator I worked with who is doing
supercomputers at MIT or Carnegie Mellon
all these people written in saying
here's a story you didn't put in and
then somehow another have a way to
crowdsource but also let an author
curate a living and growing book I hope
we have that I hope that's an innovation
we'll have in five years or so
especially if there's a way to have like
a Bitcoin or cyber currency that allows
anybody to create something for a book
like that to get a piece of the
royalties or a piece of the payments for
the book and there's one vote so far for
da Vinci we'll see how this crowdsource
goes in the next 40 minutes alan and
fullerton california you're on book TV
on c-span 2 with
Isaacson thank you thank you for taking
my call
thank you and thank you mr. Ison for the
wonderful books and helping us
understand a little bit more of the
people that are shaping the way we live
look forward to the next book in your
opinion is there another arcing trait or
characteristics that all these
innovators share something that in your
view transcends time space back from
gender I feel that they innovate in
spite of all the turmoil and all the
stuff that's going on there they just
challenge that right what what is your
opinion thank you I think that a couple
of trades are important as different as
Ben Franklin is from a Steve Jobs they
both have a rebellious spirit or they
all do
I mean Einstein runs away from high
school Benjamin Franklin does Steve Jobs
drops out of college maybe that's why I
don't get asked to speak at a lot of
graduations because most of the people I
know seem to run away or drop out but so
they have a rebellious spirit to it
Steve captured that heat jobs captured
that when it comes back to Apple and had
to write a manifesto that becomes a
television ad and you may remember it
here's to the crazy ones The Misfits the
rebels the round pegs in the square
holes because the people who think
different the people who are crazy
enough to think they can change the
world are the ones who do and Steve had
a motto when he was doing the original
Macintosh we put up a pirate flag above
the building where the Macintosh team
was and said it's better to be a pirate
and to join the Navy I think you would
find that in Einstein you'd find that in
Franklin that ability to question
conventional thinking to think out of
the box while still knowing what was in
the box and to challenge conventional
authority and received wisdom that to me
is awesomely important if you're going
to be an innovator
Benjamin Sorensen tweets into you mr.
Isaacson who in today's world most
closely lives up to those featured in
your book is innovation limitless
innovation is limitless as I said about
Elon Musk whose answer number one
to that question it's harder to do in
the non digital world than in the
digital world in other words you can do
Facebook in your dorm room but if you're
going to do things like biotech or
rocket ships or batteries or electric
cars that is a you know you say it's a
lot more regulation you face the need to
not only innovate but to collaborate
build teams and push the bounds of
reality
I love the what Larry Page is doing at
Google I think Jeff Bezos is awesome
because he's connecting commerce to
innovation and just like bursting out
into cloud computing so I mean so we're
all empowered to put us you know to
create businesses in the cloud as iBM is
doing as others are doing now but I just
think Bezos is truly awesome
I think the way Sheryl Sandberg and Mark
Zuckerberg are doing Facebook creating
it is not just a social network but a
platform upon which to build things
that's really cool I think we're seeing
innovation all over the place I ran into
Tony Fadell yesterday you know he was
the person who helped design the iPod
but now he's creating an Internet of
Things where my thermostat in my garage
door and my whatever it may be you all
connected and I can you know sort of
help my life become better through
connecting things so there's a there's
just enormous innovation one interesting
question is everybody I've mentioned you
know is in the u.s. why is it we're more
innovative society I think because we
allow people to question authority there
was a discussion by code pink earlier I
didn't like I mean I was appalled and
horrified and didn't like what the code
thing people did to Henry Kissinger but
you know what we live in a country where
that happens in China and other places
maybe there isn't as much questioning of
authority so maybe you don't get as much
innovation Becky Kurtz tweet as head of
the Aspen Institute who is the most
fascinating speaker you've heard in the
last year uh you know we've had great
world leaders from Tony Blair to you
know Simone Perez Hillary Clinton you
know people are
Barack Obama's air before George Bush
people and the elder George was
well-spoken the Aspen suit I find the
people who are doing new things at the
cutting edge say science and policy and
technology who are less well known who
come to Aspen ideas festival will come
to our action forum or come to our
strategy groups you know whether like
Eric Lander take him somebody may not
know I hope you like to book some day so
you'll have them on but he does he's
helping do complete more sequencing of
the genome in the Broad Institute of MIT
and Harvard but he's a humanist as well
so he understands how we're going to
have databases and have our genetic
material how that's going to help us
build new drugs and everything but how
our privacy concerns are going to be
affected however we may have to have a
system where you say count me in
I want my genetic you know information
to be shared so that people can make
things or I don't want it
those type of things those fascinate me
and that's why I like being at the
Institute because it's not just about
political stuff it's about real
interesting issues with science
intersect with society policy and
business that I hope we can have
practical solutions Lee Bullhead City
Arizona please go ahead with your
question or comment thank you took me
seven calls and about an hour to get
through that time here welcome second on
the Vincey okay I want you to think of
the baby for a minute a baby born knows
nothing there is no language they don't
know a house from a dog but what they do
is they watch and they listen and as
they grow older they begin to get more
curious about this and that and I think
the curiosity is the key to all these
people some other things are rebellion I
agree with collaborating because you
can't live on Islands challenge it there
all the things are true but I think that
curiosity is to keep everything Leigh
Whannell do in Bullhead City fun what
are you doing Bullhead City
I'm retired and I've got about 500 books
in my motel room and what are you from
what are you retired what am i retiring
from what are you retired I don't think
he got the time good and the most
important one to me was when I was
refueled I met her tuber newspaper Oh
same with me thank you sir
you talk about curiosity yes that to me
is something that you see in every great
innovator I'm so glad you raised it
let's take Einstein for example when he
was about six years old his father gave
him a compass and they looked in the
needle twitch and it pointed north no
matter how he turned it and it was
mesmerized by it because nothing's
touching the needle there's no particles
hitting the particles in the needle so
he's trying to figure out what is a
force field you know how does how does a
field work like that now look you and I
probably remember getting a compass when
we were kids and it's like wow it point
and then a moment or two later we'll oh
look at dead squirrel and we're on to
something else there was a passionate
curiosity for Einstein on that compass
meal that when I said he was on his
deathbed trying to get a unified field
theory connecting gravity particle
physics and relativity and all of the
series a unified theory it was basically
still like curiosity that came from why
does the compass needle twit and point
North and you can see that in Ben
Franklin he's like why does it take a
ship a little bit less time to get to
Europe and to come back and he measures
as a 17 year old the temperatures of the
water as he's failing to England for the
first time and he sort of is able to
chart the Gulf Stream so hat I know I'm
sorry worrying about why is the sky blue
things you and I might not even question
or keep being curious about he questions
the obvious so if I had to list straight
I would put collaboration I'd put
rebellious miss I put a passion for
perfection like Steve Jobs had but I've
also put curiosity up there debarker New
York City this probably isn't the way to
ask a question of mister
Isaacson live on book TV at the moment
that if it is here's my question this is
the way debarker why does the innovators
not include Jack Kilby I realize you
couldn't include everyone
but Robert Noyce is there wait I've got
a whole big ol sec I love Jack Kilby
Jack kilby's in the book in two
different places and the wonderful I
mean a Jack kilby's great plus his Nobel
when he gets a Nobel Prize and he has
such a wonderful answer when the Swedish
Academy says the whole digital
revolution comes from your thing he said
it reminds me of what the beaver said to
the rabbit at the foot of the Hoover Dam
which is no I didn't build it but it's
based on an idea of mine so kill be a
noise co-inventors of the microchip
noise how did what is now Intel Kilby a
texas instrument the ability to have
that rivalry in that race but then also
to collaborate and work together maybe
maybe the index is messed up is it in
the intelligence yeah okay too big but
but again I urge people to read about
Jack Kilby because I just truly admire
his spunk his spirit his ability to
figure out how to etch transistors on
silicon so creative and then doing it
and they have an intellectual property
dispute I've you know Cobb trade I am a
patent war over who did it and it takes
four years to go to the court and
finally the people of Texas Instruments
like kill B and the people like noise
and they say let's just settle this
let's just cross license let's move on
yep big section on Jack Kilby in the
innovators Brian in Wimberley Texas
you're on the air please go ahead oh
good afternoon just wanted to say that
I'm really enjoying the conversation and
I wanted to the reason why I'm calling
is I'd like to put a place a suggestion
to mr. Isaacson sometimes the head of
the Aspen Institute and actually I'm
doing it more in the way of a plea and
the suggestion is thus the Aspen
Institute as you mentioned earlier on
the show folk
is on developing leadership and there
are two critical issues that are
illustrated by three books one of which
you reference in your other books as
influenced you or books that you're
currently reading well those two areas
that I'm thinking about are the problems
that exist currently with Wall Street
and what I specifically have in mind
is the behavior that Wall Street engaged
in that eventually resulted in the
recession the second thing and this
relates to the book that she referenced
is the dysfunctionality in our health
care system and the three books that I
have in mind I said Brian can you get
two can you lift those three books so we
can get some more calls in here sir
three books that I think do really good
job analyzing this that book the
America's bitter pill another book
called thirteen bankers and by Simon
Johnson done another book called of in
bed with Washington I believe by Larry
Doyle but I think those areas would be
excellent areas for you to you know
focus
thanks I agree with you Stephen brill's
book bitter pill which started as a Time
magazine cover is an amazing look at the
dysfunctionality of our health care
system and I would certainly tout it and
ask people to read it I haven't read the
other two books I think when it comes to
the financial industry one of the best
things we could do is have a disruptive
type technology you see the glimmers of
it in Bitcoin I think as people build
coin base and other type wallets and
blockchain type systems we'll be able to
have a digital and cyber currencies that
provide alternatives to some of the
banking system and might enable commerce
in a better way George is in Fort Myers
Florida hi George
I George for listener me we are
listening sir please go ahead with your
question or comment for Walter Isaacson
Einstein described himself as a
determinist just like Mark Twain did and
I'm wondering how they got there you
know the issue of freewill versus
determinism is one of the richest most
difficult topics that people wrestle
with since Plato and Socrates certainly
Einstein wrestles with it certainly
Steve Jobs wrestles with it and I'm not
sure anybody's ever going to resolve it
it's at the core of alan turing's
imitation game question which is do we
have free will in a way that's different
or consciousness and free well in a way
that's different from a pre-programmed
machine ison was a determinist but of
course he wins the Nobel Prize for his
quantum mechanics or quantum theory
paper on the photoelectric effect which
basically says that at the subatomic
level things happen by chance their
statistics but not determinacy and
there's an indeterminacy at the
subatomic level which by the way means
as an int indeterminacy at the basis of
the universe so Einstein as much as he
likes to believe in a deterministic
universe comes up with the theory
it says the universe may not be that way
so even Einstein never cracked the issue
of determinism and free will so
certainly I'm not going to be able to
Einstein however was not truly a
relativist even though that is how he
was interpreted by many including some
whose disdain was tinged by
anti-semitism mm-hmm what does that mean
that means that when he does a theory of
relativity as I said to the previous
caller he actually believes that laws
that determine things and so it's not as
if time is totally relative he's saying
that there's a relationship between time
and motion but that that is the law that
determines how time and motion go
together so he's not saying everything's
relative he's saying there's a you know
a certain laws that
can be expressed in the equations of
special and then general relativity
now what happens though is people who
look at the theory of relativity
especially as anti-semitism is growing
in Germany think it sort of ties into a
relativistic morality and the relativity
of you know people who are doing art and
plays and music with all of Stravinsky
doing music where the old laws of you
know tonal chords are being broken and
there's a resistance to modernity by the
way we see that today people who resist
modernity whether it be in the you know
Muslim world or in America who resist
change and there's Einstein saying that
the fundamentals that you've always
believed in that time munch is wearing
whatever no there's a relativity now he
wasn't as I say a relativist he believed
in laws of nature but the people who
criticized him saying he's saying
everything is relative we want certainty
and that was part of the anti-semitic
backlash against what was called Jewish
science where do you write I write at
home usually and I write at night I'm
somebody who from 9:00 p.m. to 1:00 or
2:00 a.m. when the phone's not going to
ring and the iPhones not going to do a
lot of alerts at me and you know things
are going to pop up on whatever I can be
in my home office writing hard and
riding alone now I'm not one of these
people who tries to be an iron person
and gets no sleep I one of the joys
about being at the Aspen as soon as I
can convince people that no great ideas
happen before 9:00 a.m. and we shouldn't
get in too early there have been jobs
like when I was at CNN where I had to be
in at 6:30 or 7:00 but I like to ride at
night I like to sleep in till 8:00 or
9:00 when I can do you write on an Apple
product I write I use Dropbox which
means that when I'm writing I just put
it in the cloud and you can use Amazon
you can use IBM them any
Microsoft has a great cloud service now
too but I've always used Dropbox so I
can be on the train going to New York on
my iPad I'm gonna call up and don't
fiddle with it I get to my office in
which we use Dell you know computers and
you know that a networked in the office
boom I can call it up there on my iPhone
I can pull it up on my you know any
device I want to so I'm not as wedded to
hardware and I think one of the great
joys we now have is having cloud
services where you know if we took a
break here and there was a computer of
on that side of the room and I wanted to
call up something I was writing I could
just pull it up out of either Dropbox or
whatever cloud service I use do you
worry about security in that way the
security of the material no I mean no
things I worry about security I'm not
you know we got hacked in of the Aspen
Institute and Chinese were reading all
of our reports and it was part of me
said we want people to read our reports
you know maybe they should if they're
spending their time translating all of
our reports it'll be good for them and
good for us I think they're things you
have to worry about on both privacy and
security but somebody reading the first
draft of one of our books is not as then
keep me up at night
Dennis Chicago Heights Illinois hi
Dennis you're Anja I
I want to thank us he's been for for
this program today and especially I'm
going to thank the author because I've
read all of his books and have enjoyed
all of them everything from the
beginning wise men all the way to his
last book the question I wanted to ask
him is I'm the Kissinger book and that
is with the release of the White House
tapes and stuff to the Nixon
administration and the like I think
Douglas Brinkley was part of it as he
changed his ideals and what NICTA
Kissinger was about at least in the
looking at the tapes he is a lot worse
than what he is portrayed in in your
book on Kissinger yeah I think we're
always getting Mormon
I've listened to those a lot of those
tapes before I wrote that book they were
many many of them available I've watched
the new ones as they've come out there's
no fundamental holy cow I was you know
it was totally different than we thought
the tapes you know really Oh revealing
because they show private conversations
with Kissinger didn't know he was being
taped and so you see them sometimes
cater to the darker side of Richard
Nixon's personality Doug Brinkley did a
great job
you know editing some of those tapes and
I'm glad they're coming out I have a
friend Evan Thomas who we've talked
about who did the wisemen with me who's
writing a biography of Nixon based on
those new tapes I mean those tapes are
weird but for historians we're talking
about we used to have letters we used to
have Diaries we used to have taped phone
conversations and tape meetings the
treasure trove for historians and but it
doesn't I don't think there's anything
that's come out since my book that
fundamentally changes the book
chapter xxxii January 1977 for the first
time in eight years Henry Kissinger
arrived in New York City without the
luxury of being born by one of the Air
Force jets of the presidential fleet it
was the week after Jimmy Carter's
inauguration and the cherished perks of
power were starting to slip away but
unlike any other previous Secretary of
State indeed unlike even any past
president Kissinger would be able by
dint of his dedicated efforts and his
larger-than-life personality to retrain
the trappings of grandeur long after he
had left office so well here in
Washington yesterday
Kissinger spoke at a lunch it's yes I
asked one of the great thing tanks here
and I think he's 92 years old and he
gave an overview of the world order and
how it affected relationships involving
Ukraine in particular in Russia that was
you know still as brilliant as you know
any analysis you'd Muncey likewise with
that code pink
we were talking about he was in front of
John McCain's Armed Services Committee
earlier in the week giving testimony he
was at the alfalfa dinner last night so
Henry Kissinger has by dint of just his
ideas his thoughts and his writing his
intellectual rigor we tamed the respect
and the trappings of power heaven knows
what is we say you say that's 1977
January yeah you know let's do the math
it's been what 38 years since a guy was
last in government most people in the
United States weren't born probably
since he was last in government and yet
he's still somebody who as much as you
may want to be appalled at the code pink
thing it does show how he's still a
dominant part of our thinking and of our
debate over how idealistic versus how
realistic I find policy should be so I
definitely respect that and as I said
I'd to pick you know a book of
understanding some of the crises of the
world now I take we'd world order it's a
Henry Kissinger and he wrote a book
diplomacy many years ago starting with
Richelieu and mednik and how World Order
happens how the Treaty of Versailles how
the you know the Westphalian system of
nation-states come to that and even now
many years later he's still able to
apply that rigorous intellectual
framework to this world do the Clintons
hold that same aura and so certainly I
especially now that Secretary Clinton is
you know going to be running for
president and don't Clinton has that I
mean you know when he comes to the Aspen
in time II we have as I say people both
parties now come but even the
Republicans and our audience in Aspen
when Bill Clinton is there doing his
tour of the world and just answering
questions and remembering everybody's
name and having read you know wonky
policy papers on how urban revival
happens in older cities with rivers and
how the creative class moves in or how
micro payments help women in India do so
he understand
and knows more than anybody else and
he's absolutely hypnotizing when he's
giving a dissertation and so he has that
are definitely lace Rancho Santa
Margarita California thanks for holding
you're on with Walter Isaacson
hello mr. Isaacson I'm 15 years old here
and before I ask my question I'd like to
say that I'm in favor of G da Vinci book
as well it seems that a lot of people my
age don't get into biographies that much
and I'd like to ask you because you're
the Steve Jobs book was my favorite book
of all time and I'd like to ask how your
writing sets you apart from others
because yours seems to be the only one I
can connect you in that genre well first
of all I think give Steve Jobs credit if
you like that book is because we've got
so truly truly interesting person and
was able to be you know revealing in
dealing with the biographer and so I I
doubt I deserve the credit for the fact
that the Steve Jobs biography is very
interesting to you but there's a larger
issue which is I think historians
especially academic historians tend to
downplay the role of biography you know
if you were professor and you sometimes
write about the great forces of history
the very beginning of my Kissinger book
I don't know if you have it there but
the epigram is a something that he wrote
he said on one of his Shuttle missions
back and forth of the Middle East he
said something like when I was a
professor at Harvard I'd used to think
history was made by great forces but now
that I see it up close I see the
difference that individuals make so we
biographers believe in the role of a
individual to bend the forces of history
a little bit and we also have to
understand because is why I wrote the
innovators that sometimes we biographers
distort history we make it seem like
it's just one person you know sitting in
the garage or a garret and having a
lightbulb moment and innovation happens
when in fact it's great innovators and
thinkers great individuals who know
to collaborate and form teams so that's
what I tried to do in my latest book but
if I what sets me apart maybe from other
academic historians is I believe if you
just tell the story of you know here's
the beginning and here's the person
here's how he grew up and you listen to
that person you read everything that
person did and you convey that that you
can tell the history of our time through
people and to me that's the best way to
appreciate the creativity that goes into
making history as a professor I tended
to think of history is run by impersonal
forces but when you see it in practice
you see the different personalities make
Henry Kissinger 1974 after his first
middle east shuttle between Golda Meir I
think Anwar Sadat well it may have been
and between great leaders what we don't
have now I mean if you're doing a
shuttle mission now you're not dealing
with a Golda Meir or even a Shimon Peres
or a Sadat or but there are times
personalities make a big difference and
by the way that was a quote I was
thinking I've almost got it right Walter
Isaacson you haven't written about
anyone who's an elected been elected to
office is that Wow yeah I never thought
of that well but Franklin does get in
the colonial assembly of the
Pennsylvania but your point is correct I
hadn't really thought about that I do
think that it is important and brave to
get involved in electoral office that
there's so many impediments to it it's
something I never did and should have
done and feel like okay if I could
rewind the tape you know put yourself
out there run for office run for City
Council and those people do get to make
a difference public service is a very
noble calling and those of us in the
press sometimes make it difficult
sometimes we make it increasingly
difficult to put yourself out there and
to be in public service in to run for
office and so yeah maybe after da Vinci
and after after Leonardo and after a
blue
Armstrong and I'll try to do somebody's
Louie and Leo what if you were to write
about an American president is there one
that pops to mind Theodore Roosevelt and
I of course love Doris Kearns Goodwin is
the bully pulpit if somebody who's
totally fascinating to me because he
rises above party I mean he's both a
Republican and then a bull moose party
but he's somebody who understands the
importance of a bully pulpit of
traveling across this country and saying
he wanted a square deal philemon you
know it's almost like the time we're
living in today a time of prosperity a
time of great technological change
people moving from the farm to
industrial great technologies coming
with exacerbating a divide between rich
and poor making a little bit harder for
the middle class so he comes up with a
square deal and unlike some of our
leaders today he says ok I'm going to do
it and I'm just going to go for 90 days
on a train and talk in every single town
about the malefactors of great wealth
meaning the bankers who were his friends
or JP Morgan's but he called them you
know malefactors of great wealth to say
we have to have a square deal for the
working person so I love Teddy whether
I'll never surpass Doris Kearns Goodwin
on them though
William is calling in from Hot Springs
National Park in Arkansas I believe that
all yes
i William mine is more comment than a
question perhaps because many of the
things I've appreciated today have been
answered already and discussed but I
would like to thank c-span for the
wonderful presentation that is made
available to all of us and then I'd like
to express my deepest appreciation to
mr. Isakson for a person presenting to
us I would call an accurate and
determine the portrayal of some of the
less from the year and maybe they'd like
to have forgotten characteristics of so
many of our great people one other
comment I would like to make is I have a
very deep affinity for Ben Franklin I
had the great good fortune as a youth to
work in a small country print shop that
printed the community
weekly newspaper and Obon would have
been right at home because I did the
printing on a washing Washington's hand
proofs I was the printer's devil it
ain't the type start now and then I
became the operator of the press leader
and you probably see the great
connection of somebody like that
so believes in the spread of information
who creates a postal system so that
ideas can move about just like the
internet makes it open and so I really
do admire that part of Benjamin Franklin
that like me and you you know look to
the newspaper love the printing love the
free flow of information and ideas and
from Walter Isaacson's Ben Franklin book
Franklin has a particular resonance in
21st century America a successful
publisher and consummate networker with
an inventive curiosity he would have
felt right at home in the information
revolution and his unabashed striving to
be part of an upwardly mobile
meritocracy made him in social critic
David Brooks's phrase our founding
yuppie you actually at one point why did
you know was there some resistance to
Franklin he was ambitious
he was entrepreneurial he had he was
upwardly mobile he would you know born
of a poor and working-class candlemaker
you know become somebody who really
wants to succeed and so I think there
was that enthusiastic
yup eNOS that I find appealing but also
I can understand why people say a little
too ambitious a little too brash Chris
and Spokane hi Chris hi I'm a big fan
mr. Isaacson thanks for taking my call
my question is if the powers that be
came to you and said here's the key and
I open up all of time to you who would
you ask to talk to a most influential
person the top of the list for you and
the person at the very bottom of the
list I'm going to just do about Chris
who would you talk to who would be on
the top of your list
um I'd like to Vinci and at the bottom
of the list I I'd like to talk to Hitler
thank you ma'am uh well I think I have
the same lesson I would love to talk to
Leonardo da Vinci about one thing that's
still a mystery to me
is that he was a total genius but
there's so much that he didn't complete
you know paintings he didn't complete
designs were you know engineering that
whenever done is it because he had a
passion for perfection is it because he
was distracted is it because he didn't
focus and tried to do so much or is it
because once he had broken the code on
something he didn't feel he needed to
put the finishing touches on it and
that's what I'm working on as I read his
notebooks trying to get that question
likewise if I could talk to Louis
Armstrong it would be okay I know
everything about you everything you did
every day but I don't know whether you
were happy I don't know why you were
smiling I don't know you know what you
felt about white people or whatever and
so sometimes you just would and I had
that wonderful fortune to be able to do
that with Steve Jobs and every now and
then I'll do a person who's alive like a
kissing door Steve Jobs every now and
then I'll do a franklin or nine sign
when you do get to talk to somebody you
can say I know everything about you but
this is still a mystery and at least in
the case of Steve Jobs page after page
in my book is him trying to explain
those mysteries well nollans finally get
some love Dwayne Bona Ferg tweets in
that I hope Walter Isaacson writes books
on NOLA and Louis Armstrong would be
great companion to Terry Teachout
excellent pops yeah now Terry Teachout
does a very good book on called pops as
you said on Armstrong and I still you
know I I you know I don't know mr. t job
but I I still I think that that has
everything about Louis Armstrong in it I
still find this some mysteries you know
well what what was the cause of a smile
and his happiness you know and so and to
me I also would like to wrestle with
that whole
of New Orleans and the the diversity and
the mix of people and I would say the
tolerance but also the end tolerance I
mean he is arrested on New Year's Day
and put in the waves home for you know
so it's not exactly Ferguson but it's
you know what's happening with kids on
the street back then and now what's
happening with stories will opens and
there's prostitution and a great sense
of tolerance but also a tolerance for
sin you know his mother was probably
turned tricks shall we say in parts of
New Orleans so all of that gives you a
sense of what's going through his mind
and I'd like to try to deal with that
and to mean New Orleans is such a
fascinating place obviously it's
fascinating you know in a complex way
but to me it's a beautiful way at the
city of masks I mean as we speak today
the Carnival season is beginning the
first parades are rolling Louis
Armstrong watch the Zulu parade when his
father we didn't really raise him would
abandon the family he really didn't
really know his father that well marched
in zoo I mean played into him on a float
in Zulu in Whiteface in a mask
signifying and in a strange way playing
all those symbols of race in say the
early 1900 and throughout New Orleans is
a city of mass you mass for mardi gras
you wear your mask and Louis Armstrong
himself I think always wore a mask I
think that smile was part of the mask
now
what Shakespeare teaches us you know
especially when towel growing up and
Henry the fourth place is we become the
masks we wear and that too is an
interesting topic to explore all right
we have four minutes left and I've been
waiting for a caller to bring this up to
questions
did Walt Albert Einstein fail math and a
years ago a book came out Einstein's
brain what the happens when Einstein
dies is without much authority from the
family the person who prints and hustle
takes his brain I mean like hey you
don't wanna lose this thing takes a
plane out of scull put it in the jar
formaldehyde and keeps Einstein's brain
in over the years he would parcel out
pieces of Einstein's brain because
people would say well I want to figure
out why was he so smart now there's a
larger issue here which is really
interesting because you can look and say
okay these grilles or this that and the
other was slightly different of this
part was like with this act that gets
back to Alan Turing are we just machines
is it just you can find in the size of
little parts of his brain the
explanation fine science genius I don't
think so I think we're not machines
we're humans so as much as they carve up
that brain as much as they slice it over
the years trying to find the secret I
said earlier on you have to look for
natural explanations for things but that
doesn't mean that under a microscope you
can find genius by looking at the cells
of a brain and no he never failed math
in fact he was really good at math
almost as good as he needed to be when
he's finally doing general relativity he
laments the fact that his bath isn't a
little bit better because the tential
calculus is starting to stumped him but
he gets some good friends to help him he
did fine in math but it's a good myth to
have because as Sal Khan says who did
Khan Academy he's doing a thing called
you can learn anything I urge our
viewers you can learn anything you can
learn math you can learn learn
relativity you can learn about da Vinci
go to Khan Academy and one of the videos
about inspiring people that you can
learn anything
so xym Stein is a little baby in a
bathtub sake there was a time even
Einstein didn't know how to add numbers
you can learn anything where is the
majority of Albert Einstein's brain
right now I think most of it is now in
Princeton Hospital whatever they've but
it was sort of parceled out was that a
fun chapter to write because it was
innocent
semi amusing and many less semi amusing
and of course there is einstein's brain
that book you mentioned that's a small
but really amusing book about it it was
fun to write but partly because it got
to that larger issue is it can we just
look mechanically and try to figure out
why he was a genius no the whole book
you need the whole book not just a
microscope on his brain to say what may
dine Stein in dine Stein David is in
Glen Shaw Pennsylvania David you're the
last word today well thank you for
taking my call I've read quite a few
books Isaacson and the last two books I
have read was Professor cocoons the
future of the mind right and your
innovators and I read them because I saw
you and him talking about them on book
TV and I think it's such a wonderful
format that have I read a lot I read all
nonfiction I'm currently reading the
devil to pay about Buford at Gettysburg
and one of my questions is do you think
sometimes of historians and and and
people that read their works don't
understand and don't bother to look at
the time that the person that you're
writing lives in or lived in and
therefore they're making assumptions
about that person based on our point of
view of today yes that historicism of
that historic fallacy has many names to
it in which you impose the standards or
ideas of today on a person I think it's
really important for readers and
historians to wrestle with that an
obvious example is when you're doing
slavery and you're trying to judge
Thomas Jefferson or Ben Franklin or
whatever to me you have to rise above
and be ahead of some of the Moral
Sentiments of your time to be a great
person which is why I think I can judge
Jefferson more harshly than others would
because he didn't do that or even
Churchill did not get on the right side
of history when it came to but but
that's me imposing a later judgment on
them you have to be aware of it the last
chapter of my Benjamin Franklin book was
the most fun to write because it's about
how
every new generation discovers Franklin
anew and sees him differently and in a
age of you know great economic struggle
he's revered as a self-made person in a
Romantic period you know like the 1820s
and 1830s people look down on them like
da Chuan's and others later look down on
him because he's not romantic and
ethereal enough so in a Benjamin
Franklin we see a reflection of our own
time but we have to be aware that we as
readers and historians are not just
judging him in the context of his time
but judging him in the larger context of
history
so does Franklin deserve the accolade
accorded by his great contemporary David
Hume of America's first philosopher
Walter Isaacson right to some extent he
does disentangling morality from
theology was an important achievement of
the Enlightenment and Franklin was it's
avatar in America in addition by
relating morality to everyday human
consequences
Franklin laid the foundation for the
most influential of America's homegrown
philosophies pragmatism that is from
Walter Isaacson's an American life
Benjamin Franklin and American Life his
first book came out in 1986 co-authored
with Evan Thomas the wise men six
friends in the world they made Kissinger
a biography in 1992 the Ben Franklin
book in O three Einstein his life in
Universe 2007 Steve Jobs which is going
to be made into a movie 2011 and the
innovators how a group of hackers
geniuses and Geeks created the digital
revolution you've been watching book TV
on c-span - this is our in-depth program
Walter Isaacson has been hired asking
well thank you that was a whole lot of
fun thank you